we bought all the chicken sandwiches
from every fast food chain in the US and
UK to compare the differences this is
food
Wars at UK McDonald's chicken sandwiches
come in three sizes the Mayo chicken a
McChicken sandwich and a MC Krispie
McDonald's in the US has four chicken
sandwich options the McChicken the MC
Krispy the MC Krispy Deluxe and the MP
cpsy and the mcris
spicy
deluxe the UK KFC options are a regular
chicken sandwich a tower Burger which is
the same but with a hash brown and some
cheese and a stacker Burger which is two
chicken patties with some cheese as well
KFC options we currently have two the
Chicken Little look at this little guy
so little and the KFC chicken
sandwich
this is part of their Gourmet Kings
[Music]
range whoops we have two types of
chicken sandwich at a UK Burger King the
chicken Royale or the steakhouse Krispy
Chicken Burger King in the US also has
two chicken sandwich options and they
are as follows I am taking this off uh
the chicken
junr this guy I mean this looks exactly
like a McChicken and the original
chicken sandwich the only chicken
sandwich we're going to see today that
is shaped like a
smartphone Popeye's chicken sandwiches
in the UK only come in one size the
classic chicken sandwich Popeyes in the
US also has but one chicken sandwich
Shake Shack in the UK only has one size
of chicken burger the Chicken Shack
Shake Shack we haven't done anything
with Shake Shack in years it feels like
but they're back they got a chicken
sandwich just on looks wo this looks
really ridiculously good Jollibee
chicken burgers come in two sizes in the
UK as a standard or as a double Jollibee
I love Jollibee and their chicken
sandwiches are very good we have their
regular chicken sandwich and the
spicy Wendy's in the US went all in on
chicken sandwiches as you can see there
are nine varieties two four six eight
yeah Wendy's only has one size of
chicken sandwich in the UK
okay um I'm sorry what sandwich is this
again and the crispy chicken sandwich
chicken BLT okay okay okay aago Club
spicy chicken sandwich Wendy's all right
we get it BLT or Club spicy ghost pepper
bacon pretzel Pub Wendy's spicy
[Music]
pretzel then we've got some options that
you won't find in the US two things from
a chain called mes a strip burger and a
fet burger and one thing from Nando the
grilled chicken burger Arby which is
only available in the US has three
chicken sandwiches starting over here
they have their crispy chicken sandwich
they have their bacon Swiss crispy
chicken sandwich and they got the
buffalo chicken sandwich chickfila of
course the original you can also get the
same sandwich spicy version raisin canes
they have of course one chicken sandwich
option on the menu this is that uh
depending where you are in the United
States these are the five Carl jr/
Hardy's chicken
sandwiches so here are almost all of the
chicken burgers you'll find in the UK
arranged by Price the cheapest at this
end is the McDonald's Maro chicken at
just £119 the most expensive is the
Shake Shack Chicken Shack coming in at
£935 for the price of one Shake Shack
Chicken Shack you could buy 7.8
McDonald's Mayo chickens in general I
think it seems like the size is tracking
with the price so they do seem a little
bit smaller down this end and a little
bit bigger down this end with a couple
of exceptions I do think the Nando one
looks a little bit small even the
Chicken Shack does look a bit small and
that's very expensive okay prices in the
US uh starting from least expensive to
most expensive the least expensive
sandwich to No Surprise is the KFC
chicken little which comes in at
$239 but let's be honest this isn't
actually a full sandwich I mean it's
almost like a little slider the most
expensive is the Carl Jr bacon Swiss
chicken sandwich coming in just the
sandwich
$11.49 you you know I think it's
interesting that McDonald's takes up
this part Wendy's is almost all exactly
right here Arby's is almost exactly
right over here I do enjoy raisin canes
but this sandwich should not be in this
percentage of price um first of all it's
chicken tender sandwiches it's not even
like a full chicken patty I mean the
Jollibee spicy and regular are you know
in the lower third this is a great
sandwich Popeyes is here KFC is right
here Popeyes and KFC positioned almost
right next to each other
price a lot of people myself included
would say this might be these might be
the best fast food crispy chicken
sandwiches on the market and they're
down here man they're like hovering
around McChicken prices here are all the
UK chicken sandwiches ordered by weight
the lightest option is the Mayo chicken
at 120 g and the heaviest is the KFC
Zinger stacker Burger 325 G key
takeaways there a few of them really
drop down for example the Shake Shack
Burger the Nando Burger has really
plummeted in terms of price versus
weight not a lot of movement at the
bottom end of the table which is
interesting I think even just visually
like the colors are quite interesting
down the Mayo chicken end the buns are
kind of very dull and quite a matte
finish then the sesame seeds kind of
start to disappear the higher up you go
and you head more towards the kind of
Brios bun which just looks a little bit
fancier in Shiner okay now this is all
the US sandwiches by weight least weight
down here most weight down there okay
once again the Chicken Little and and
the Wendy's Krispy Chicken is at the
very end of the smallest and all the way
down here at the end the Wendy's classic
pretzel bacon pub at a hefty 284 G on
this one heavy sandwich I don't know
what you want to do with this
information really the one thing I will
notice is the most expensive one or the
one of the most expensive ones is the
weight right in the
middle so certainly not charging by
volume shame on you Carl Jr Popeyes
right Popeyes is over here move this way
all the way up so lesser in price more
in weight let's go and here are all the
chicken sandwiches arranged in order of
price by weight so the best value in
terms of price by weight is the
McDonald's Mayo chicken per 100 G of
burger that will cost you just 99p the
most expensive by weight is the Shake
Shack Chicken Shack per 100 G of burger
that one will cost you
£425 the Shake Shack Burger is 329 more
expensive than the Mayo chicken I guess
ultimately it comes down to personal
preference as to whether you want to pay
a little bit more for what you would
hope to be higher quality or if you kind
of just want value for money and
quantity over quality I think when it
comes to fast food I kind of just want
value for money I just want to leave
feeling satisfied with my food for as
little price as possible I'm kind of
surprised how low down in the value
scale the chicken Royale from Burger
King and the standard phip burger from
KFC ended up you're really not getting
that much value for money when compared
to some of these options and I don't
think the quality of either of those
chains is necessarily high enough to
justify that price point for example I
think the jollie double chicken sandwich
as well as the Zinger stacker Burger
you're getting a lot of food for your
money there and honestly these are
really tasty Burgers so the quality is
good price is good I think these ones
are what I would lean towards in general
if I were to order this this is order
from Best Value to worst value coming in
[Music]
at is a Wendy's BLT look at this little
guy what a deal I love the fact that
both the Popeyes and the KFC chicken
sandwiches are arguably the best deal
you can get in the US look at this if
you're going per 100 gr the Chicken
Little isn't as good of a deal as a full
chicken sandwich I love it um glad to
see the pretzel buns are down here cuz
these were the heaviest but also
comparing it with the price you get a
pretty good deal I think from here on
it's like yeah okay um back here
Jollibee spicy chicken glad to see it
great deal MC chickens over here huh
raisin Canes All right I was a little
tough on raisin canes before
everyone's favorite Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A here and here really really
this is your favorite restaurant we're
Clos on Sundays for this give me a break
Shake Shacks over here I don't know I
was enticed by its size but I have to
run in the numbers it's not that good of
a deal shame on you Shake Shack I know
McDonald's even McDonald's isn't safe
they're mccrispy all the way over here
for this
one that's surprising and annoying look
at this look at this every Carl Jr most
expensive right they weren't the
heaviest worst value the Carl Jr hand
breaded not even the ones with all the
fun stuff on it just a regular hamb bred
sandwich here you go it was
$10.99 and it weighed 221 G so it's
$4.97 per 100 G I know it's a lot of
data to throw at you let me just give
you the tldr too
expensive
so here are all the UK's standard
chicken sandwiches I'm going to taste
them all back toback and provide you
with my definitive ranking here are the
standard chicken sandwiches at several
us fast food chains I'm going to try and
rank them right now McDonald's MC
Chrispy let's give this one a try
they've gone really heavy on the
Mayo the bun is quite fancy it's fancier
than you'd normally find on a McDonald's
burger it's kind of like a pretzel bun
effect nice shiny decent texture on it
not too doughy chicken patty maybe a
little bit thin it's a good place to
start cuz I think there is room for
improvement there but it could be a lot
worse so starting whe down here the
McChicken classic I mean I feel like I'm
been biased because been eating these as
long as I can
remember I'll put it here for now I feel
like I mean it's good for its value but
I don't know a little basic now I don't
think I've had this one before the
Burger King
one M Sim actually I like that better
yeah be okay all right next up we got
the KFC phip burger by the looks of
things also just mayo and lettuce and
chicken overall it's just lacking a
little bit of something it's quite Bland
I think so far whether it's the chicken
the breading or the Mayo not quite as
flavorful as the MC Krispie so slightly
below it I mean come on popey's chicken
sandwiches has been sitting for a while
this is the one that everyone lost their
minds about on the internet so
everything I'm looking for still crispy
amazing Pope ice flavor love the bun
little bit of mayo or sauce on there not
too overpowering wow that's great that
they'll stay in this region big
competitor though KFC ooh and this one
this is still really crispy all
right here that crunch yeah I'm going in
for another bite
the Burger King chicken Royale I'm
tempted to dock points just because of
how stupid this thing looks I've never
understood why they made it
long I think the ratio is slightly off
the bun is obviously a long bun but it's
also quite thick so if you can see there
you're getting like quite a lot of bread
to meet ratio yeah that's the worst one
so far um Wendy's we saw we'll see it
later but Wendy just had you know 100
freaking
sandwiches dry barely seasoned no that's
that's that's that's the worst one was
cheese on this no no not very good
popey's chicken sandwich popey's is a
relatively recent addition to the UK we
didn't have this until maybe a year or
two ago and I will say so far people
seem to be liking it on this one you get
the chicken the Mayo and instead of
the lettuce you get pickles which I
think is more of an American thing I'm
one that I enjoy cuz I love
pickles this is good I think we have a
lader so
far the chicken I would say is thicker
and crispier than any of the three I've
tried so far get little like crunchy
bits that flake off the
edge so yeah I think my favorite so far
poyes Arby I mean
they got the meats and I guess chicken's
a meat but I don't think about getting
chicken when I go to Arby's it's roast
beef
right that no like flavorless you know
Shake Shack Chicken Shack is up next
this is the most expensive of any of the
burgers we've tried today it looks
pretty fancy the bun is that classic
Shake Shack bun I think it's a potato
roll
we have chicken mayo and lettuce no
pickles in this
one I was wrong there are pickles in
this
one the breading on the chicken it
looked like it was going to be tasty but
in actuality doesn't have that much
flavor and if you actually look at the
chicken it's quite a thick piece of
chicken but it's like very dry and quite
tough I think it's probably worse in the
MC spicy so I'm going to tuck it in
there
here we go let's get everyone fighting
in the comments with Chick-fil-A never
been a Chick-fil-A fan and I hope
everyone watching can see what varieties
of chicken sandwiches you can get at any
fast food chain while you're picking
this what are you doing what are you
guys doing I've never really cared for
Chick-fil-A it's just the epitome of
fine I mean this is looking closer to to
these ones than it is to these over
here looks really
dry
got to get the sauce got to put sauce on
it so I got Chick-fil-A sauce but I mean
the fact that it's like no you have to
put sauce on it to enjoy it well okay
then put the sauce on it why do I got to
do
it I do really like the Chick-fil-A
sauce it's a very good sauce I will say
what this has going for it other than
these is that its
Simplicity makes it to me a little
better cuz it's not bogged down with
like a lot of like soggy vegetables or
or sauce or whatever when you add in
this instance the Chick-fil-A sauce it
is better so for that I'm going to put
it let me put it down
here it's definitely not as good as a
McChicken um I just don't see what the
big deal is I don't and never was going
to flood my comments with uh the
specialty orders I have to get with the
saas and then no this is the sandwich is
on the menu I got it I tasted it boring
and blend up next we got Jollibee the
classic chicken sandwich also a
relatively new addition to the UK let's
give it a
try wow I think it's the crispiest
chicken we've had so far I think it's
even crispier than the popey's one could
maybe benefit from a little bit more
Mayo it's just slightly dry my main
criticism so far there's not much to
separate this and Popeyes but I think I
slightly prefer the taste of Popeyes so
I'll tuck it in there yo raisin canes
though chicken tender sandwiches
someone's head chef is a 12-year-old boy
um not a bad idea just stick the Tenders
in a bun throw some sauce on here let's
go
cool here's why this is smart with the
tenders there's more surface there's
more like surface space so the crispy
skin to chicken ratio leans more towards
the crispy chicken Chi or the crispy
skin which makes it just gives it a lot
more
flavor I really like raan cans I know I
was disappointed when put in the value
Matrix that Harry came up with but you
don't want to Discount taste is a very
tasty chicken sandwich so oh Raisin
Cane's another one that's famous for
having like this cane sauce you're
supposed to dip it in and I didn't even
put any on here it's still good so
Chick-fil-A extra sauce then we're on to
the Wendy's plastic chicken sandwich
well looks like quite a dry bun chicken
patty lettuce ooh tomato and
pickles just visually I had quite low
expectations but that's a pretty tasty
sandwich not bad I'm going to put it
slightly below the MC Krispy all right
last
two uh Shake Shack is great I don't
usually go there that often cuz I always
feel like it's a little more on the
expensive side and Aesthetics alone this
looks like it would have
been maybe the best one it looks like a
big piece of chicken yeah good amount of
sauce I like the the bun this this looks
like a big chicken sandwich
right this is really
good
yeah the flavor of the chicken is
popey's and KFC level I mean it canes is
cool everything this way has more of a
generic fried chicken flavor but from
here on the flavors are getting more
specific which I like and Shake Shacks
wow then we've got two UK exclusives to
rank as well I'm going to start with the
Mory phip Burger this kind of looks like
the platonic ideal chicken burger that
you might
find just a lettuce quite a lot of mayo
chicken looks good not the thickest
piece of chicken but looks pretty well
seasoned the chicken I would describe
the texture as leathery quality-wise you
can kind of tell that the chicken in
here is maybe not quite as good as some
of the other ones I think it's down here
actually not as bad as the long chicken
and last what we've determined arguably
the worst
value for your money Carl Jr oh man but
they're really emphasizing that this is
a handre it they're doing it by hand
back there let's how it
tastes
hello this is actually pretty good oh
man I've been dogging on Carl Jr all day
okay
all right raisin canes is better than
this one but not I
mean it's close this one has a they both
have a unique flavor can's overall has a
better lasting flavor they don't taste
exactly the same but Carlos junr your
hand bred chicken sandwich is actually
pretty good then our final option is the
Nando grilled chicken burger it's some
of that signature grilled chicken with
your chosen spice level Leon chose the
spiciest one for me thank you and it's
served on these kind of uh I think it's
a Portuguese
roll which have quite a firm texture to
them I will say you can taste the
quality of the chicken with this one the
ratio is slightly off I've always
thought this bun is like quite a lot for
the rest of the ingredients it's good
but where does it rack I think this may
upset people but I'm actually going to
put it slightly below M Krispy and that
is my ranking coming in dead last Burger
King chicken Royale and I think my
favorite is the popey's chicken sandwich
going down the ranking ranking from
least to best says me in last place we
have was this Wendy's yeah but of course
the top two Popeyes and KFC and I want
to say at any given day it could be
popey's 1 KFC 2 those guys are neck and
neck um depending on the KF KFC and
popey you go to oh my gosh I almost
forgot Jollibee this is the standard
Jollibee
sandwich I'll put that between the MC
chicken and the um Chick-fil-A yeah not
not impressed it's a lot of chicken I
keep track
of now we're going to talk about all the
US sandwiches you cannot get in the UK
here are all the chicken sandwiches from
the UK K that you won't find in the US
only we call them chicken burgers
firstly is the return of the value King
it's the Mayo
chicken this is as simple cheap and
cheerful as it gets it's a slightly
oddly shaped usually Square chicken
patty with some mayo and some lettuce on
a bun and for a few extra pants you can
also add bacon and have a bacon Mayo
chicken then we have a linguistic
difference in the UK our spicy version
of the chicken sandwich is called a milk
spicy you guys call yours a spicy milk
Krispy which to me seems like an
unnecessary amount of
words whatever I like spicy milk Krispy
it's like a pirate
[Laughter]
name
y then we're on to KFC in the UK instead
of having a spicy chicken sandwich we
have a Zinga Burger it's basically the
same thing same Patty but the breading
is a bit more spicy I quite love this I
think generally speaking I'll opt for a
Zinger Burger over just the classic fet
burger also do Americans find it weird
that we pronounce it fet burger and not
filet cuz uh I feel like you guys will
find that weird unless you're talking
about the fileto fish from McDonald's in
which case we say filet figure it out
our next exclusive from KFC in the UK is
the tower Burger so this is the chicken
but then they add some cheese to it and
a hash brown we've also gone for the
Zinger Tower burger here which means
that you get this spicy saler sauce
on top as well and then we have the
exclusive Zinger stacka Burger now this
is our largest burger that you can find
on a KFC UK menu and it's if I can
separate them which apparently I can't
it's just peeled instead it's two
chicken patties with cheese between and
on top lettuce spicy mayo and some more
spicy sauce on top as well while we're
talking about the KFC ones you'll note
that on the UK menu they're all named a
burger rather than a sandwich it's hard
to explain exactly where the linguistic
difference comes from I think a lot of
it comes to do with the bread that your
sandwich comes in I think generally
speaking if you have like a round bun
particularly with sesame seeds on it in
the UK what's inside it is just going to
be called a burger we actually have
quite a few chicken exclusives on a UK
Burger King menu we'll start with this
one which is the steakhouse crispy
chicken this is part of their Gourmet
Kings menu that's how I describe
myself there's a tomato sauce on the
bottom a crispy chicken patty big slice
of cheese bacon and then what looks to
be some rocket on top for the American
audience we call arugula rocket I've not
had this one before it was quite
expensive I think it's got Gourmet in
the name and I think they're using that
to uh put this at quite a high price
point it's not bad I do think to get
this as part of a meal you're like
pushing £10 in the UK and I feel like
once you've hit that price point just go
somewhere else just go to a restaurant
cuz you'll get like better quality
fresher food for probably the same if
not even less money there's a linguistic
difference to point out which is that in
the UK we call our weird long Burger
King chicken burger a chicken Royale in
the UK we can also get our chicken
Royale with bacon and
cheese or we can get a Californian
barbecue
Royale so that is the standard Royale
with the chicken the the lettuce and the
Mayo but also quite a lot of barbecue
sauce and also some tomato on there
surprisingly we actually have a couple
of popey exclusive sandwiches that you
don't have in the US here we have the
deluxe chicken sandwich and the spicy
deluxe chicken sandwich now while a
regular Popeye sandwich is just sauce
chicken and pickles these ones have
sauce chicken pickles but also lettuce
and cheese with the standard one the
sauce is mayo and on the spicy one it's
actually the sauce that changes rather
than the chicken this one having a spicy
mayo instead I don't know if adding a
little bit of lettuce and cheese to
something is enough to qualify it as
Deluxe I think if you're calling
something Deluxe I'm going to need a
little bit more than that guys but I'll
give it a
try you know what I'm going to say it I
think the deluxe sandwiches are worse
than the originals from Popeyes I think
for the couple of extra pounds that has
costing you to add a little bit of
cheese and lettuce to your sandwich
you're better off without it honestly
the next exclusive was actually a bit
surprising to me it's this one from
jollie the double chicken sandwich it's
surprising in the sense that the UK is
the country of excess here for
once we're the ones with
the much larger portion this is a hefty
Hefty sandwich we have one exclusive
chicken sandwich from the UK Wendy's
which is the avocado chicken club so you
get the chicken patty with some cheese
on top
and then you have some mashed avocado
bacon lettuce and tomato not to be outd
the UK also has quite a few chicken
chains that you won't find in the US and
interestingly our chicken sandwich
culture is quite different to yours now
in terms of chains Nando is obviously a
pretty iconic chicken joint over here in
the UK now what you can find some of
these on the east coast of the us over
here they're in pretty much every city
in town and are kind of like a
foundational part of UK culture at this
point we're now so obsessed with Perry
Perry as a flavor that almost every
restaurant that sells chicken will have
a Perry Perry option and you've seen
lots of other chains try and spring up
to capitalize on the popularity like
roosters and pepe now we can't talk
about British chicken sandwiches without
talking about chicken shops chicken
shops are an integral part of UK and
more specifically London culture the big
players are mes and chicken Cottage but
there are literally thousands of
independent ones scattered across the UK
they're so popular that people are
ripping off the big chains now so you'll
see things like monley and mes opening
up with deceptively similar branding and
Decor to the classic Moy chain to put
into context just how popular chicken
shops are there are currently around
8,000 of them in London McDonald's has
just 200 locations a funny thing is how
some of the independent chicken shops
aren't just ripping off other ones like
moy's but they're trying to rip off the
big chains like KFC I think in the UK
people don't really understand what
Fried Chicken means when you refer it to
a specific US state so I'm sure to
Americans they will know the difference
between Kentucky Fried Chicken versus
something that was fried elsewhere but
in the UK we don't really have that
context in the UK you might walk down
the street and see Ohio Fried Chicken
Maryland Fried Chicken or Alaska Fried
Chicken uh as an American yes Kentucky
does have a distinct type of fried
chicken um Popeyes is
Louisiana other southern states have
their own ways of making fried chicken
yeah Nashville hot fried chicken that's
another one which is a city and not a
state yes I realize but yeah Alaska no
Ohio no Montana no no Montana has no
Cuisine another thing to point out is
that when it comes to the big chains
like mes and chicken Cottage the
individual shops are often franchised
Leon swears by the thoron heath mes he's
a South London guy and he say the best
one if you've been to a better one let
us know there isn't a better
one now we going to talk about all the
US sandwiches you cannot get in the UK
uh going to go by Chain so McDonald's
for instance you can get a deluxe crispy
chicken sandwich which is just the
regular chicken sandwich with lettuce
and tomato Mayo on it um and and then
you can also get the spicy version the
sauce is a little bit orer which I guess
it makes it spicier Burger King I saw it
in there year what was it your you guys
called
this the the burger Royale and ours is
just the original crispy chicken
sandwich sub sandwich shaped like that
for seemingly no specific reason yep
KFC the Chicken Little that's a little
guy you can also get your chick-fil
sandwich spicy version um look spicier
it comes in a red bag cuz red is hot and
spicy is hot I mean everything the
Carlos Jr was a exclusive I think cuz
you guys don't even have
one it just seems like we kind of just
throwing everything at the wall and see
what sticks crispy chicken with
bacon I feel that Wendy's especially
Wendy's and Carl Jr they just are trying
to like do variations on a theme hoping
that we'll kind of get everyone I
understand why but it's a bit
overwhelmed right I mean I don't even
know which one to get I don't want to I
don't want to bite any of these these
look bad this whole section here is just
like throw everything in the wall and
see what sticks I don't I don't agree
with that strategy guys just by the
looks of all these sandwiches the
flagship chicken sandwich at each one of
the chains I would more go for than any
of these I'm just I don't want any of
these from exclusive items to portion
sizes we wanted to find out all the
differences between Ikea food in the US
and the UK this is food
quick note it turns out Ikea does not
offer a takeout option but fortunately
they do sell lots of Tupperware
containers so in case you're wondering
why the food looks a little bit sad it's
because we had to improvise on with the
video Let's Start portion sizes with
Ikea's claim to fame when it comes to
food the Swedish meatballs in the US
Ikea's restaurant offer only one portion
size for meatballs eight pieces but
after that you can get them in
increments of four for
instance 12 me meatballs in the UK
Ikea's iconic meatballs come in two
portion sizes eight or 12 you can also
add four extra meatballs to any order
for an extra .75 and there's seemingly
no limit to how many times you can do
this in the UK the meatballs come with
either mashed potatoes or chips on the
side as well as some Garden peas Ling
and Berry jam and of course their famous
gravy and of course the meatball options
all come with a side of mashed potatoes
and peas let's get a load of that also a
little bit of cranberry sauce we're
going to weigh eight meatballs in both
countries to see whose meatballs are
bigger 1 2
[Music]
3 Let's also try and weigh our Mash now
I do feel like the uh stats might be
skewed slightly because there's some
peas embedded in this I will try and
free it where I
can we got way more mash than the UK
like almost
double they're feeding us at our Ikeas
vegans and vegetarians Rejoice Ikea also
offers vegetarian vegan versions of its
meatballs right here we're doing a blind
taste test plant versus
meat that's definitely plant- paste
what's the next
one oh was that wrong wait okay wait
give me another one okay this is the
other
one yeah that's me not even close not
even close thank you Peter neither were
bad and if I was a vegetarian or vegan I
would be perfectly happy with those
plones tasted perfectly fine but that
the the the difference is noticeable we
share a couple of dessert options with
the US notably the dime cake over here
we call that the caramel almond cake
let's weigh a
slice another dessert option we share
with the UK is a soft serve ice cream
which you get in vanilla or strawberry
okay first of all the gentleman who
worked there was adamant that's actually
frozen yogurt I don't know if that's
true or not regardless they didn't have
to go cups like Harry was able to get so
all they would give us is like the small
cup where it's kind of poking out like
it's ready to eat it is 97° in Los
Angeles today there's absolutely no way
that was making a from Ikea to the car
let alone the studio so here's footage
of me enjoying it in the lobby of Ikea
so I'm sorry I didn't bring the scale I
don't know how much it weighs we have
soft serve ice cream in the UK too
either as vanilla or vanilla with
chocolate sauce impressive they've given
us exactly 100 G of soft sa ice cream
Ikea is also known for its hot dogs in
the UK you can get either a classic hot
dog or a veggie hot dog from the beastro
stand we're going to measure and weigh
the classic hot dog to compare with the
US the hot dog in the UK is 7 in in
length and with the toppings of pickles
and onions it weighs 114 G hot dog our
hot dog is 5 and 1/4 in long and our hot
dog weighs 75
G
here are all the menu items from a UK
Ikea that you won't find in the US
here's all the food you'll find in a US
Ikea you won't find in the UK starting
out down here hot Entre this single
piece of chicken is the Havana chicken
that doesn't come alone it comes with
plantains rice and beans which we will
see in a little bit but just isolated
the chicken has been sitting for a
minute sorry Havana chicken I wonder
what makes it so
Havana yeah I'm definitely getting some
spices in here very flavorful not just
like a standard piece of chicken it's
actually really good we'll start down
this end with some main courses we have
two different non-meat meatball options
in the UK firstly we have the veggie
balls these are meatballs which are
formed of ground up vegetables and
they're also served with a vegetable
cuscus as well but for vegetarians who
prefer something a bit more reminiscent
of meat they also have plant balls now
I'm kind of intrigued by these cuz they
look really good these are a fake meat
version of Ikea's classic meatballs now
compared to a classic meatball they're
actually like almost more visually
appealing I would say they're a nice
dark golden brown color they look like
they've you know been cooked in a
similar way maybe even kind of like
fried or cooked for longer than you
would expect from these let's do a very
quick taste test classic
meatball we all know and love it these
things are delicious and then one of the
plant
balls I will say the plant-based one
doesn't have that distinct Ikea meatball
taste to it that said still pretty tasty
I think texture wise it's like almost
identical to the classic meatball you
you also get a salmon fillet with pea
pesto vegetable medallions and a corn
medley which you can see right here I
mean Salmon's okay I guess okay this
isn't it's been sitting for a while if
you like salmon
sure I don't know you got I ke salmon
pea pesto is interesting though still in
the mood for
fish Before You Go furniture shopping
you can also get the garlic lemon cod
with of course mashed potatoes and peas
actually that's a pretty good piece of
fish you actually really like that okay
I stand correct that I was dissing I was
dissing The Fish actually actually
pretty good we have a British classic
dish and that's fish and chips now the
fish they serve at Ikea in the UK is
pollock it comes with chips peas and
some TARTA sauce now unlike fish and
chips that you might find from a classic
chippy in the UK they've actually
breaded their fish rather than battered
and then fried it I generally prefer the
battered fish texture I like the kind of
crispy crunch on the outside that you
get from batter I'm gonna have a little
little try of this it's very weird
tasting things on food Wars using a KN
and Fork I don't like it I respect that
they have attempted to localize their
menu to the UK Market but maybe put a
bit more thought into your R if you want
to see what proper fishing chips looks
like go and check out our food tour's
best fishing chips in London video next
up we have another fish option it's a
salmon
filet come
on next up we we have another fish
option it's a salmon fillet in the UK we
generally lean more towards fillet as
the uh wording and also we spell it
slightly differently often we spell it
with two L's whereas I believe in the US
it tends to be spelled with one I think
you can get a salmon fet in the US
however like we say we pronounce our
slightly differently and also in the UK
our comes with the veggie cuscus chicken
tenders the fries and
broccoli wait these tenders are actually
very good like the breading they're
really breaded te and Fries Hardy Ikea
also has a few things on the menu that
were not available at the one we went to
a chicken thigh with garlic chipotle
sauce broccoli and rice sounds actually
pretty good lingan Berry barbecue ribs
with mac and cheese ah I was so mad they
didn't have those and a plant-based
burger with fries also not available at
time of filming this now Ling and
berries are majorly popular in Swedish
Cuisine and you're going to see them pop
up a few more times in the Ikea menu
next up is pen pasta with tomato sauce
pen of course refers to the shape of
pasta that they use here in
Ikea Charlie love that really weird is
that the only analysis you're going to
give what does pen mean p refers to the
shape such a
strange I think pen is maybe my least
favorite pasta
shape I do not respect pen moving
swiftly on from the pen we have a
chicken katsu curry I think this is like
a relatively new addition to the UK Ikea
menu so katsu refers to the chicken
katsu fillet which is a breaded and
fried piece of chicken and then it's
served with rice and katsu sauce I've
not tried this before that looks like
one just massive piece of chicken you
know oh why you eating it science other
than a couple of like slightly
disconcerting dark patches inside the
chicken breast it's actually not bad I
think because of the size of the breast
it's dried out quite a lot but the katsu
sauce is really nice I like it with the
rice I think particularly if we're eaing
this hot this actually would be pretty
good next up on the UK menu you can find
a pot potato and cauliflower Rogan Josh
Curry a Rogan Josh is a curry that
you'll find on the menu of a lot of UK
Curry houses it's not super spicy
generally quite mild I'd say
traditionally you would see this made
with lamb but they've made a vegetarian
version here obviously with potato and
cauliflower as the main bulk of it the
Rogen Josh from Ikea is served with rice
and you can also get some side options
which are designed to go with it
including some pakoras samosas and a
garlic Nan obviously the UK has a large
British Indian population so I do think
this is another attempt to kind of
localize the menu
that's pretty good that's pretty
flavorful there are some other main
course options from UK Ikeas which
unfortunately we couldn't find today
these include such things as butternut
squash and sweet potato soup Mangalore
chicken curry butternut squash blue
cheese and caramelized onion pie chili
sin Car garlic butter chicken pie and
leak and potato soup I would like to
move on the sides right here we have the
vegetable medallions I like veggies
presented like this just like in a
little puck just bite into it looks like
it has some broccoli mostly potato
friendly almond yeah not bad decent side
it's like you know it's like broccoli
potatoes like broccoli mashed potatoes
The Havana chicken that I mentioned
earlier this is the beans and rice it
comes with I don't know if they mix them
up or just got mixed up in transit but
no beans and rice let's go this is just
white white rice black things like I
don't taste any additional flavor to
this at all they do sometimes offer
plantains again the iea we went to today
did not have plantains but they did have
a garlic
bread I think that's an exclusive on to
the IKEA cold dishes they have a h
veggie dog well the veggie dog wrap is
under of the cold dishes according to
script and this veggie dog is cold maybe
it's been sitting a while either way
it's not very good also they have a
Greek salad I'll the Caesar salad which
once again I mean this is a pretty low
effort a Stockholm
salad uh not to be confused with
Stockholm syndrome which I'm starting to
feel right now eating this food salmon
lettuce
lemon
sure that's that's that's not bad
actually I like this sauce that's
turning color under these lights and
this salmon we're not quite sure what is
in the salad with the sauces right now
but through the miracle of editing we
can put that on the screen right
and that's what it is tastes pretty good
also you get a BLT chicken wrap not bad
if you like wraps and BLT and chicken
also at us Ikea which was not available
at time of filming this at our burbing
Ikea is a Greek veggie ball wrap and
marinated salmon the UK's cold Plate
menu is pretty bland in comparison the
only one they had today was this
marinated salmon plate but we can also
get an egg and shrimp sandwich with mayo
marinated salmon r wrap small salad bowl
and a tomato and mozzarella salad I
guess I'll give the salmon a quick try I
do like smoked salmon here of course
they call it gravx because it's the
traditional Swedish way and it comes
with a dill sauce and some lemon fairly
mild flavor I like the kind of herb
crusting that you get the dill sauce is
pretty Dilly and now on to desserts
there are three exclusive Ikea us
desserts I was only able to get one of
them so the first would be the
Strawberry Shortcake not available time
of shooting this the second is this the
caramel almond cake and the third is the
infamous chocolate layered cake also
known as The Conspiracy cake I asked
everyone there please tell me you have
chocolate cake and they all said no no
chocolate cake at the Burbank IKEA today
at least tragically we don't have the
conspiracy cake here in the UK but we do
have some other exclusive dessert
options for example this delightful
looking Strawberry Tart there's some
real pieces of strawberry in there I
like the pastry I like the cream I like
the fresh strawberries whatever the kind
of strawberry syrup jelly stuff that
they've kind of put around the outside
is it's okay but it has like a slightly
almost like medicinal quality to it that
I don't really love it almost reminds me
of calpo I don't know if you have that
in the US but it's like a medicine
that's marketed towards children in the
UK next up we have Ikea's famous dime
cake now you do have this on the menu in
the US however I believe you guys call
it something slightly different I think
caramel alond cake is dime not a
particularly big brand name in the US
because over here in the UK I'd say most
people are familiar with dime as a
chocolate brand uh Harry was just
talking a minute ago about the dime cake
the DM cake Dam cake I've never heard of
it I've never heard of that brand I have
no idea what it is I'm sorry but we do
have this which I think is supposed to
be
similar oh yeah this is fantastic I'm
getting one of these every time I go I'm
going to get one of these and I'm going
get that chocolate cake I'm going to be
lookout for it now it's maybe not quite
as popular in the UK as it used to be it
reminds me of my granddad a lot cuz he
used to really love a dime bar I
wouldn't see many people my age going
for it but still very tasty if you're in
the mood for it and this cake is
Sensational you get these layers of
chocolate this kind of biscuit crumb and
these kind of like I almost pancakes in
the middle I think these dividing lines
might all almost be kind of cold chilled
pancakes this might be my favorite thing
on the menu this is why I'm making
excuses to go to
IKEA they did have these at the
register and this also says dime on it
we see that yeah okay this tastes like
this never heard of this but it's very
good and this is fantastic and maybe
there's rebranded it cuz no one in the
US knows what dam cake dime cake is our
next dessert option is a cheesecake with
blueberries and raspberries it's a very
soft cheesecake really like easy to cut
there's like a nice baked crumb on top
there's a layer of the berry stuff so
there's some blueberries in there some
raspberries then finally we have these
Under the Sea Rocky Road biscuits
obviously Rocky Road in the UK is is a
dessert which is usually like a nobaked
dessert made of things like melted
chocolate golden syrup marshmallows even
things like corn flakes pieces of
biscuit that sort of thing all just kind
of mixed together left to set and then
you have a nice easy dessert it turns
out what makes this under the sea is
that they have a kind of animal stamp in
icing on top of it here we have this
nice octopus and here we have a couple
of
dolphins I think when I eat a rocky road
I kind of want some more distinct
elements I like being able to bite into
it and crunch through a bit of biscuit
or chew through a raisin or something or
with this one that's kind of all Blended
together so you don't really get the
like texture contrast the flavor is very
much there it's still all those elements
that I'm used to in terms of the flavor
you may also be able to find some other
dessert options on a UK menu which we
couldn't find today these include things
like a caramelized biscuit cheesecake a
chocolate Clementine bomb an elderflower
and lemon cake a gooey chocy cake a
lemon cheesec cake rhubarb and custard
cake and a strawberry jelly aside from
It restaurant Ikea also has the Swedish
Beast for quick bites the beastro serves
quick bites like hot dogs and pizza
slices that you can generally grab on
your way out of the store few exclusives
we had of course was pizza slice there
it is I went with cheese is is this like
Costco or like surprise Ikea has amazing
Pizza this is a really good slice of
pizza I can't tell but I think this was
a oven cooked fire oven cooked mat just
like the pizza this has like
a yeah a thick oven it's not as good
Costco but it's pretty good wow weird
Ikea's got good pizza good on Ikea you
can also get this giant beastro pretzel
look little I like a little braid here
look at me I'm a Jedi but you are not a
Jedi yet and it comes with mustard they
didn't have the mustard either man I
don't know is it cuz I went at 10:30 in
the morning and the stuff hadn't shown
up yet they didn't have
anything a pretzel with no
mustard
also at the US Ikea beastro you can get
a marinated salmon baguette they didn't
have we have a few exclusive beastro
options of Our Own in the UK firstly if
you like the onions on the hot dog you
can just get a side of fried onions next
up we have these which are chick list
strips so these are a plant-based
version of a chicken tender I say they
look pretty good they kind of passed the
visual test yeah when I T this apart I
was worried that the texture wasn't
going to be right and unfortunately it's
not it's very spongy it's very mushy it
just seees a little bit more texture
it's just something to make it resemble
a chicken tender a little bit more
obviously when you get an actual piece
of chicken tender or chicken breast you
can kind of tear it and you see those
strips and the fibers they just really
haven't got that hair flavors not too
bad though we can also get chips from
the beastro in the UK it doesn't seem
like you guys can do this in the US we
have our veggie dog option which comes
with the same toppings as the regular
hot dog so here we got fried onions you
can also get some with Pickles the
veggie dog in the UK isn't like a
plant-based meat thing it is just
vegetables so it looks like there's some
kale in there some carrot
maybe like some mustard seeds I think
that with the fried onions with the
pickles and some sauce actually a pretty
good veggie option then we have some
drink options notably milkshakes in the
UK you can get milkshakes in four
flavors vanilla chocolate strawberry and
banana we got a banana one today a
little
sip that's not bad pretty gentle banana
flavor it's mostly just ice cream but
with like a little bit of flavoring in
now which who can who could say no Aira
in the UK does serve breakfast although
unfortunately when we arrived today they
weren't serving it the options that
you'll find there are pretty much
everything that you would normally find
on a full English breakfast so it
includes things like bacon sausages hash
browns beans tomatoes mushrooms black
pudding sometimes you'll find things
like Patty skun as well and you can also
get white or whole milal toast if
breakfast platters aren't your thing
then you can also just go for some fruit
or some porridge
breakfast The Breakfast Platter in the
US also comes in both regular and small
sizes and it's made up of eggs potatoes
bacon Swedish pancakes and now supposed
to be top of the lingan berry jam and
then give it to us the US breakfast menu
also offers a Skagen croissant sandwich
which is a croissant filled with
traditional Swedish shrimp salad and
didn't happen I think Ikea has its own
line of drinks available in its
restaurants the US Ikeas you'll find
Cola sugar-free Cola sparkling raspberry
juice lingen berry juice and sparkling
lemonade I went ahead and got the lingan
berry juice straight up no idea what a
ling Berry is it's fantastic there's no
difference in the size cups you just
have glasses that are the same size or
these to go cups or whatever we have
some drink options at the restaurant in
the UK that you guys might not have in
the US there are a couple of options for
kids which are these pip organic juices
we have a couple of Robinson's options
in the UK Robinson's is probably the
most popular brand of squash in the UK
and this is basically just a diluted
version of the squash squash for those
who don't know is like a concentrated
fruy drink that you kind of water down
to have a nice refreshing beverage you
can get a peach and mango version or a
raspberry and apple version and if you
feel like celebrating any of your
purchases that you've just made from the
Ikea you can also get alcohol we have
three alcoholic options on the menu at a
UK Ikea a rosé wine a red wine or a dark
logger finally Ikea has a Swedish Market
where you can buy prepackaged food items
to take home the items on offer include
some of their classic foods like the
meatballs which you can buy frozen or
some gravy sachets which you can make at
home in the UK you can also find the
plant-based balls on offer in there you
can get a whole frozen dime cake which I
taking home and eating all by myself and
speaking of dime you can also get the
chocolate which the cake is based on
here it's in bite-sized form rather than
as actual chocolate bars but as you can
see it's chocolate with a kind of hard
caramel Center Charlie has dibs on these
another thing at the
US
Ikea maybe not exclusives per se but of
course they have a whole thing of Frozen
stuff I just grabed stuff that was
interesting come on the cinnam the cinn
Buns huh the cinnamon buns me balls and
you know we were talking
about the dime cake but they do have it
frozen to take home and of course it is
the dime
cake let's compare the nutritional
information of some iconic Ikea dishes
in the US and the UK in the UK eight
Ikea meatballs contains the following
342 calories 25.1 G of fat 8.2 G of
carbs and 856 mg of sodium in the US the
same plate of Swedish meatballs contain
304 calories 22.4 G of fat 6.4 G of
carbs 592 mg of sodium the UK takes this
round in every category what about the
IKEA hot dog in the US it contains 260
calories 15 G of fat 24 G of carbs and
780 mg of sodium and in the UK the hot
dog contains 293 calories 15.2 G of fat
29.5 G of carbs and 78 mg of sodium
looks like the UK version is higher in
calories and fat once again USA
Baby what's actually in the iconic Ikea
meatballs according to the IKEA website
if you want to make their meatballs at
home use the following ingredients beef
mints pork mints onion garlic
breadcrumbs milk egg and salt and pepper
to taste for this are actually the
ingredients list for proper Ikea
meatballs well on the back of the Frozen
packet you'll find an ingredients list
according to this packet they contain
beef pork water breadcrumbs egg dried
onion salt egg powder black pepper
extract and all spice overall it seems
like it's pretty close to the list that
they gave you on the website with a few
more things like powdered ingredients
versus fresh ingredients and a couple of
spice differences too I wasn't able to
find it online or in the cafeteria the
ingredients list but I got
here the Frozen precooked meatballs and
those ingredients H actually not bad
assuming these are the ones that they
have in the cafeteria in the US uh the
ingredients for this is Beef Pork water
breadcrumbs made of unbleached wheat
flour salt yeast whole eggs salt
dehydrated onion egg white that's not
plural egg white singular
spices that's not bad I think for a
prepackaged product right it's like well
that's you know that's what's in them
right while we're on the subject of Ikea
ingredients one thing that UK viewers
might remember was our Infamous horse
meat
scandal back in 2013 a number of foods
in the UK claiming to be beef or pork
were actually found to contain traces of
HSE meat while this wasn't necessarily a
health issue it did raise some major
questions concerning the traceability of
foods throughout Supply chains and
unfortunately Ikea was also caught up in
this Scandal Czech authorities found
traces of horsse meat in some Ikea
meatballs that had been produced in
Sweden and shipped all around Europe
thankfully the horsse meat meatballs
were found before they reach consumers
in total 760 kg of Meatballs were
destroyed given the fact that there's no
health concerns related to the
consumption of HSE meat I think they
should have just leaned into it just
passed them off as like limited edition
horse meat bowls and Just Go With It
Lads it's
fine Ikea's Food is Almost suspiciously
cheap it's actually one of the ways it
tricks you into spending more time and
money in its stores Ikea is basically
willing to take its losses with its
cheap food prod prices because it's
counting on you to spend a bunch of
money on furniture and other household
items a former Ikea executive even
referred to the meatballs as the best
sofa seller in the UK a plates of eight
meatballs peas Mash or chips gravy and
linger Jam will set you back just £4.95
at the time of recording that's around
$649 I do have to say that's really
cheap I don't think the quality is that
bad it's really tasty food and yeah it's
a real bargain I will make an effort to
go via the restaurant if I'm just going
through Ikea even if I'm just popping in
for like one or two bits I'm gonna sit
down eat a plate of Meatballs it's good
value it's tasty I love it an eight
meatball meal in the US is
$9.99 which in the UK is £780 that's a
54% increase in the
states overall I would say Ikea is
pretty popular in the UK it's most
people's go-to for basic furniture and
household needs I would say especially
when people are buying a house or moving
house or something like that personally
I love Ikea I love going there I do
enjoy a trip it's fun I like the food I
like walking around and pretending like
oo that could be my apartment or my
bedroom or my kitchen I wouldn't say Ika
is somewhere I go often particularly
because I live in quite Central London
and there aren't many in central London
I think they're trying to open one on
Oxford Street right now at the time of
recording this it wasn't open but
they're kind of trying to get there but
so like I say it's more of a place where
you'll go specifically when you need to
do an Ikea shop Ikea is so popular here
I think it's popular in the whole
country um the one in Burbank we went
there at 10:30 in the morning morning it
opens at 10:00 and at 10:30 parking lot
was pretty full the cafeteria line was
full so I'd say Ikea is pretty popular I
personally wouldn't go to IKEA just for
the food again it might be because I
don't live close enough to one to make
that worthwhile I do love the food the
meatballs are great like I say the
desserts are fantastic but I don't like
it to the extent that I would make the
effort to travel to one just to eat that
I'm not going to say I go to IKEA for
the food but the food definitely is a
good motivator to go to IKEA I will say
all I do enjoy the experience of going
to an Ikea I am aware that it's kind of
designed to make us spend money
obviously the restaurant plays a part of
this as well cuz it's kind of
encouraging you to make a day of your
trip to Ikea really spend some time
there sit down take a break in the
middle of the day eat re-energize
yourself and more shopping and as you
can guessed by my friends on the table
with me here I do think that their
marketing is a really clever ploy to
make us spend more money there as well
I'm joined here by my friend dungl skog
I'm really sorry I'm going to butcher
these pronunciations and uh my friend
blah who is the adorable little sh dark
who is also I think a trans icon love
that you'll often see things like this
really getting like a reputation on the
internet driving more Commerce to Ikea
stores I don't know if they're doing
that deliberately or if it's just kind
of like a side effect of making some
very very cute plush toys but everyone I
think will generally have at least one
thing from Ikea in their home so
whatever they're doing it's kind of
working I'm not mad about it either I
support Ikea keep up the good work guys
I've just been informed by my fellow
producer Uli that they went on dates at
Ikea explain I'm gonna what honest it
kind of seems popular for couples cuz
it's like something to do and see
yeah I didn't think that's a good way to
get to notice some first you start
eating the food's Dirt Cheap so great
okay great and then you're walking
around and they'd be like this is the
kind of couch I like this kind of art I
like you're like no they that huh if
this goes we're thinking about it's
going this is the kind of bedroom setup
they want to I don't know and also if
the person starts like dogging like you
see something that you like and they
start dogging on on it you're going to
be like this not going to work out from
calorie counts of portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between poptarts in the US and the UK
this is food
wars in the UK pop TTS come in one main
size an eight pack you might also be
able to find a 36 pack online but these
seem more geared towards retailers
rather than consumers so for the
purposes of food Wars we're not counting
them in the US our Pop-Tarts come in
seven size varieties down here we have
the two pack eight pack tow 12 pack 16
pack the value pack 32 pack the family
pack I don't if you can see it says
family on there and the biggest amount
the 48 pack they probably also come in
one box that means our biggest Pop-Tart
variety is 33.3% bigger than what you
can get in the UK but other poptart is
the same size in both countries let's
measure them to find out so our UK
Pop-Tart was 8 cm wide and 11 cm long
for a surface area of 88 cm squared we
will do the same three
by four and of course we're going to
weigh it and a Pop-Tart in the US weighs
48 G our UK po tart was bang on 50 g
which I think is actually slightly more
than it's supposed to weigh Kelloggs uh
work up feeling a little generous today
but what about the pastry to filling
ratio I hear you cry well don't worry
we're going to look at that too you can
sort of like chisel off layers of pastry
I mean there's really not much Jam in
there that's a very thin layer of jam
right there think we might have toon
this just go real bad so unfortunately
we had to abandon the scrape test
because that was not working Joe if you
pulled that off you're a genius I don't
know how you've done it however on the
back of the box of the poptarts it says
that the fruit filling should be 34% of
the poptart by weight if our matter
correct this was a 50 g poptart 34% of
that should be 17 G of jam yeah any all
right hat hat hat hat
ow
ow get WIP it on here right w will round
up to 10
G so that is this percentage of
jam here's all the Pop-Tarts you can get
in the US you can't get in the UK and
here are all the poptarts from the UK
that you can't find in the US yes it's
just the
one we got all of them want to get this
out of the way real quick there are
currently two limited edition Pop-Tarts
out right now the red white and
blueberry and the the strawberry
throwback I went to Walmart guy said
they didn't have them also newer ones
there is an Apple Jack frosted apple
cinnamon one which is supposed to be
delivered to my house tomorrow I'm sorry
but one new one we do have is frosted
banana bread which is looks like a
poptart gave us some extra frosting up
top
there yeah it tastes like banana bread
actually it's very good you can only
find three poptop varieties on sale in
the UK including strawberry sensation
frosted choco tastic and hot fudge sunde
these two you can also find in the US so
they're not exclusives but this one is
the Frosted choco tastic while it has
its own name it does seem a little bit
similar to the US chocolate fudge one so
we'll take it out and have a look so
this is a UK frosted choco tastic
poptart it's got the chocolate icing the
pastry itself is chocolate flavored and
then it's got these little flexs of
white stuff on it ambitiously in my mind
I was hoping might be like flaky sea
salt but it's a Pop Tart I think it's
more likely to just be some
icing not too bad you also have a
chocolate filling on that as well so
there's kind of like three levels of
chocolate going on here not too sweet
either actually all right starting with
the Frosted chocolate F let's compare
this to what hair we
got chocolate on
chocolate I I going to say the obvious
but this is like really chocolatey and
fudgy see as we only have three poptarts
I figured I'd try the other ones too
just to see how they stack out against
the exclusive choco tastic so this is
our version of hot fudge Sunday pastry
wise looks kind of similar to the
chocolate one with the chocolate pastry
but then it has something more
resembling the strawberry icing I feel
like this is probably a slightly lazy
attempt to just kind of rehash things
that already have into a new product The
Filling looks pretty similar to The
Filling found on the Frosted chocolate
tastic slightly lighter in color so
maybe they've gone for more of a fudge
Vibe rather than just straight
chocolate I think with a combination of
the standard icing and the slightly
different filling this has more of a
well-rounded balanced sweet flavor to it
and of course the classic strawberry pop
top obviously visually this stands out
because they have not gone for the
chocolate pastry it's that very kind of
almost alarmingly pale pastry color
pretty much the same icing I think that
they've used on the chu fudge
Sunday this the classic for a reason
it's just PR good a blueberry all right
getting some fruit I wouldn't be able to
guess what fruit this was just but on
the outside a
minute here in the years so for one
thing I've noticed they're really
skimping on the filling I know it's like
dusty but brown sugar cinnamon beat up
ooh this like really smooth also very
dusty I honestly can't tell if the
flavor is the frosting or the jam Cherry
I I feel this is like a flagship one
aim's not so great over there in the
factory already though both on this side
and this side you can almost see the
filling coming out of it
right I'm starting to think a lot of the
sweet fruit flavor is coming from the
frosting and not the
inside chocolate chip all right already
this can we get that satron bone please
it's like so it's like a doctor's
signature it's just right across it I
can't read this what does this say
oh
poptart o this really irritates me this
really winds me up you got to be kidding
me with
this your mom or your school or your
work whenever doesn't get Oreos they get
the knockoff brand sandwich cookies and
it's like you'll eat them but you're
like ah man kind of want an Oreos that's
what this tastes like it says like a
knockoff of an
Oreo frosted conf fatty
uh don't make me eat this please don't
make me eat
this it's like just eating straight
frosting next up frosted hot budge
Sunday breakfast is served this looks
like an absolute nightmare imagine
eating this and going to school totally
phoned in like
drizzle it's very
sweet oh man a Pop-Tart s'mores Uli's
Choice okay it tastes like a s'mores you
can see a little pocket of marshmallow
there this is the first dual filling I
think I've had or least I've noticed and
you know what I don't really like it I
can't believe we only had one exclusive
I feel like I'm really missing out on
some of those tasty American poptarts
Joe can I get some of those no worries
man I got
you thank you so it looks like Joe has
kindly shared with me some confetti
cupcake poptarts the American version of
the hot fudge Sunday poptarts and some
frosted s'mores poptarts frosted
confetti I feel like Americans are just
obsessed with eating sprinkles because
it seems like every kind of brand
whether it's chocolate pastry will have
a kind of confetti cupcake birthday cake
flavor and poptarts are no exception
American sprinkles look so much better
than British sprinkles I know it's
because they are using banned chemicals
which we don't have over here we have to
opt for natural alternatives but when it
comes to baking they just hold their
color so much better they look a lot
more vibrant I kind of get why you guys
are using
a doesn't give me any pleasure to admit
it but that is really tasty it's got
almost like a sort of cake batter taste
to it that filling so it kind of is like
you're eating a confetti cupcake or at
least the batter of a confetti cupcake
in my left hand I have a British
strawberry sensation pop top in my right
hand I have the American frosted
confetti cupcake one just quickly wanted
to point out the color difference
because that is wild next up is the
American version of the hot podge Sunday
poptarts the American version with the
these look so much more fun than ours
size-wise they look pretty much the same
but the American one looks
thicker the American one has this white
icing filling whereas in the UK I think
they've gone for more of a kind of like
fudgy chocolate filling the difference
between these two is Kind of Night and
Day the American one better than ours in
pretty much every way I tasted this at
first and I wasn't disappointed by it
per se but now that I've had the
comparison a direct comparison with the
US this St like eting cardboard finally
it's the Frosted s'mores popt I got to
say s'mores aren't really a thing in the
UK in the UK we don't have graham
crackers or as we would pronounce it
graham crackers shout out to my dad
gram yeah there we go there we go it's
almost like a digestive biscuit these
are pretty good this one looks maybe the
scariest it's cookies and
cream whenever it's frosting inside I
know I'm in
trouble yuck don't give this to a child
ever and most adults should also not eat
this grape grape
fruit ones look how I think a pops are
supposed to look they don't look that
intimidating grape is a really popular
flavor in the US but anyone in the US
will tell you that grape flavored candy
doesn't really taste like grapes they
somehow invented a grap like Flavor
probably because grapes have like a
weaker flavor I think I'm not quite sure
exactly how it came to be but this
tastes exactly like that fake imitation
Bubblicious bubble gum great you know
what I'm talking about a grape soda it's
not bad so far the all the fruit ones
are better than any of the other ones so
yeah ego how un natural looking is this
you know you can take those classes I
think they're called like Sip and paint
where everyone like Paints the same
picture same still life while they're
sipping wine with their friends this was
the image they were painting and this is
what they painted
drunk this does not in any way taste
like an Egle waffle I don't think it
tastes like waffles at all what ruins it
Z is this frosting on here this is so
sweet raspberry I have a feeling this is
going to be a good one
yeah top chair right here these were
optimized for fruit filling wild berry
so it's just the combinations wild or
these were found in the wild oh
no alarm bells in my caveman DNA is
going off do not eat this is poisonous
do not eat warning warning your
ancestors who ate this died let's go
against millions of years of evolution
and bite into this woefully bright
colored piece of I'm assuming food we'll
find out
together with all the frostings on here
it's actually not that sweet compared to
the other fruit
ones played this part of the video to uh
the ambulance driver when he asks what
happened Boston cream Boston cream donut
is this dut right here if you haven't
seen it you can't even tell where the
cream is in that compared to the color
of the the
pastry what I'm about to say will come
as no surprise to anyone watching this
video but this one tastes completely
artificial I know right can you believe
it on to the next smaller
pyramid Snicker
doodle Bland all right then look at the
unfrosted ones unfrosted unfrosted we
got strawberry brown sugar cinnamon and
blueberry unfrosted V frosted I was
complaining how sweet they were so maybe
I'm more of an unfrosted guy and I don't
realize that but this looks weird this
looks like an army
ration this one is sweeter but not that
much sweeter don't you think with the
frosting would be night and day they're
pretty similar simply frosted Harvest
strawberry there you go no artificial
colors color from natural
sources once again regular strawberry po
pop tarts it look pretty similar right
this has more frosting on
it wow they taste exactly the same as
the artificial ones one other thing that
we wanted to talk about was The Toasted
versus untoasted Pop-Tarts debate now
people have been debating for years
whether it's better to eat your
Pop-Tarts toasted or straight out of the
packet I will say in the UK this is less
of a debate because I feel like most
people are more likely to toast their
poptarts even though they are safe to
eat straight out of the packet however
we did notice that on the American ones
that Joe sent over there are some
varying instructions which kind of
confused us apparently in the US you can
microwave them which you're supposed to
do in bursts of 3 seconds until they're
hot enough to eat despite the fact that
the British ones explicitly tell you to
not microwave them I'm assuming at some
point someone tried to microwave them in
the foil and was met with a nasty
surprise and also the American ones say
that you can freeze them and eat them
Frozen don't know why you would do that
Frozen or semi- Frozen pastry does not
sound like it would be nice but we're
not here for microwaved or frozen
poptarts we're just going to heat a
couple up in the toaster oven and then
compare them to some toasted poptarts to
see which ones I prefer all right toasty
boy going in let's see if we can uh
Rectify
that
also did what did you notice what is
with Harry's giant toaster oven and the
size of that thing just get a regular
toaster
T SMS like toasted
pastry hey oh and has fallen apart
there's breaking apart
already
untoasted yeah toasted is way better the
fillings more flavorful the crispiness
of the pastry I isn't too lazy to toast
them so this one on my right is the
untoasted version and on my left is the
toasted version I got to say visually
not a lot has changed I was hoping for a
little bit more Browning while it was in
the oven still not much of a snap from
the pastry even when toasted but you can
see that the filling has slightly
liquefied really impressive that they've
actually managed to create a pastry that
doesn't just burst and leak all of the
filling when it does get toasted I say
impressive probably just uses a lot of
chemicals whereas when you compare it to
the untoasted one even when you kind of
Squish it down that filling is not going
anywhere I do prefer the toasted version
as I sort of expected I think the main
difference for me is actually in the
filling obviously the flavor doesn't
change a lot when you toast it it's more
the texture I think just the fact that
it does liquefy slightly gives it a much
more pleasant texture when you actually
bite into this thing also in the US you
get something called Pop-Tarts bites
these guys right here I have strawberry
of course and uh confetti cake but you
can also get brown sugar cinnamon
frosted blueberry frosted chocolate
fudge and strawberry banana I have no
idea what these
are no these are not good Pop-Tarts also
does collabs with other brands for
instance there's a Pop-Tarts Jenny's ice
cream coffee mate has its own Pop-Tarts
flavor and of course Pop-Tarts cereal it
was originally called Pop-Tarts crunch
discontinued but they renamed it after
they brought it
back in the UK an eight pack of
strawberry poptarts cost you
£2.99 which is around
$386 that same box in the US is
$449 or
347 a 16.3% increase in the US oo with
the gouging come on guys it's not
surprising to me that Pop-Tarts are
really popular in the us we love a quick
and convenient breakfast they have
positioned themselves in their
advertising as a more convenient
breakfast than cereal cuz you know
inconvenient cereal is you got to get
the box and the bowl and the spoon and
the milk and sit down and eat it not
Pop-Tarts cereal too much work Pop-Tarts
way easier for me the price increase
prop portion makes sense because I've
always seen Pop-Tarts as more of a treat
than an everyday breakfast food it was
the sort of thing that my mom might have
let me had as like a weekend treat
breakfast if I had accompanied on her
weekly shop and been very well behaved I
will say that the marketing in the UK K
explicitly doesn't brand these as a
breakfast food compared to something
like cereal there is no mention of the
word breakfast anywhere on here they
just referred to as toaster pastries so
I guess they could be construed as more
of a snack is the lack of breakfast talk
the same in the US Joe or are you guys a
bit less Shameless about marketing
desserts as breakfast foods for children
so I originally thought this was
supposed to be breakfast food but Harry
makes a good point it doesn't say
breakfast anywhere on here even the box
says you can get them straight from the
foil toasted stacked or frozen but they
really are not saying anything about
breakfast
so I went back and looked online in the
9s I looked on YouTube I found a bunch
of commercials where they said
specifically for breakfast the even
quote part of your complete breakfast so
they did sometimes Market them as
breakfast foods and then sometimes not
and just for me it's sunk in that yeah
you have these for breakfast in the
morning when you're in a hurry to get to
school or
work here is the nutritional information
for one strawberry poptart in the
UK let's be honest they come in packs of
two so we're going to double those
numbers for a more accurate serving size
reading thank you ER because in the US
we go straight for the two tart serving
size and here our strawberry pop tarts
are it looks like the UK numbers are
actually slightly higher than those in
the US so I guess that means we're
winning now if calories are your thing
in the US our cinnamon brown sugar
Pop-Tarts have the most 400 per serving
how about
weight the
unfrosted have even more calories 410
per service
I don't know how that works either in
2021 somebody sued Kelloggs claiming
that Pop-Tarts contained way less
strawberry than what was presented on
the packaging this case was ultimately
dismissed as the judge said quote no
reasonable consumer could believe from
Kellog's packaging that The Breakfast
Table hey breakfast perfect okay
contains only strawberries or more
strawberries than other ingredients such
as pears and apples the US packaging
actually States the strawberry Pop-Tarts
contain 2% or less of dried strawberry
berries here are all the ingredients of
a UK strawberry sensation frosted
poptart one thing to know is that the
gelatin used in a UK poptart is
explicitly labeled as beef gelatin so
unfortunately this means that British
Pop-Tarts are not suitable for
vegetarians and here are all the
ingredients in a US strawberry
poptart of the many differences between
these two lists there are a few
ingredients we wanted to highlight here
the first is tbhq or tur bual
hydroquinone
to be honest
quite this is a preservative which is
used to extend shelf life or for added
freshness as the US label States the FDA
has put limits on how much it can be
used tbhq can account for more than
0.2% of the oils in a food because the
FDA doesn't have evidence that greater
amounts are safe while that doesn't mean
that more than 0.2% is dangerous it does
indicate that higher safety levels
haven't been determined research has
linked tbhq to health problems the
National Library of Medicine found
Vision disturbances when it was consumed
by humans as well as liver enlargement
neurotoxic effects convulsions and
paralysis in laboratory animals
Pop-Tarts in the US also contain
synthetic food coloring which are
restricted in the UK specifically Yellow
5 yellow 6 red 40 because of their link
to hyperactivity and in attention in
children goly G I can't imagine why the
brain is going all over the place
another thing to note is that the
poptarts Joe sent me are technically
Contraband items if you're working with
the police or the government and you
watch this please do not extradite Joe
we need him for filming that's because
the flower used in US poptarts is
bleached bleaching flour has been banned
in the UK since the 1990s over concerns
about potential health effects it also
just seems unnecessary to me especially
for something that's going to be toasted
and darkening color anyway you guys just
love putting chemicals in your food and
seem to seize any opportunity you can to
do it yeah don't arrest me but he did
ask me to send it so I will flip on the
UK team in a second FBI if you're
watching I will wear a wire it was all
Harry's idea I will help you take him
down from calorie count to potion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Hard Rock Cafe in
the US and the UK this is food
War let's break down the burger that
started it all the original legendary
Burger let's weigh the US Burger 318 G
here's the original legendary Burger in
the UK let's weigh it our Burger weighed
280 G that's a pretty big difference
from 28 80 to 318 G this is a heavy
heavy burger and of course all their
burgers come with a side of seasoned
fries we're going to weigh ours to see
how much we're getting so our side of
fries came to 178 G they feel so soggy
right now on my hands so that is 126 G
of french fries another iconic menu item
is baby back ribs we're going to weigh
our UK portion to find out how much
we're
getting is that too
heavy
335 plus oh God 300 635 G this is heavy
this is
82 G of ribs that sounds like too much
ribs for one sit down dinner that's a
lot of ribs the cowboy ribeye is
supposedly 16 o of beef let's see if
that's actually true this is
12.8 oz of meat meat does shrink so a
little wiggle room is to expected but
feel like that's pretty decent Chunk we
booed everyone's booing everyone's
booing me so after being booed by
everyone I I'll be more upset about
losing out on some of this meat it just
looks like such a big portion that I'm
like it's fine but it is 4 oz that were
missing that was advertised so I
understand I understand why everyone's
upset strangely the cowboy ribey is
advertised as being 14 o here in the UK
I'm not sure why we're getting short
changed but we're going to measure it to
keep them honest so our UK cowboy ribey
has actually only come to 10 and 1 half
oz I understand that steaks do lose some
of their Mass while cooking but 3 and 1
half o that seems like a lot let's get
into some apps we got the classic nachos
no meat this is food Wars so you know we
got to weigh these nachos
602 GS here are the UK nachos I'm going
to weit them with the paper cuz our scal
has had enough trauma already a UK
nachos weigh 510 Gram I'm interested to
see which country has bigger Wing
portions so let's count them out count
them out with me we have
one two three 4
10 11
and 12 7 8 I'm going to let them have
this one I'm going to let them have this
one because we've literally been
destroying them in these portions sizes
this entire time so you know what you
deserve the extra amount of wings Hard
Rock Cafe is also known for its famous
onion ring tower now on the menu they
don't specify how many onion rings you
get in a tower however in a promotional
photo I counted eight so we're going to
count ours out now and see if that's
true or if we get more or less than we
were promised I'm going to try my
hardest to beat Harry in the onion ring
Tower making somehow built this uh the
wrong way around so it's getting wider
near the top
six seven
I'm not doing that
again
8 9
10 girls in stem so while my tower
design failed horribly we did get 11
onion rings in our onion ring Tower as a
side what about dessert let's compare
Hard Rock's apple cobbler in the US on
the UK it smells so good I'm resisting
every urge I have to bite into it right
now we've got got
432 G of apple cobbler so the apple
cobbler in the UK came to 376
G here are all the menu items you'll
find at a hard rock in the UK that you
won't find in the US here's all the food
that you'll find at Hard Rock Cafe in
the US that you won't find in the UK
there are a couple of burgers you'll
find in the US but not in the UK the
turkey burger and the impossible Burger
I think impossible beef isn't available
in the UK yet there's an ingredient in
it called soy leg hemoglobin which is a
approved in the US but not in the UK The
Impossible
burger that soy leg hemoglobin is doing
what it needs to do that's the
ingredient that makes this taste like
actual beef um and it's working it's
working for me I can tell texture-wise
in the back of my head this is not beef
but it's like doing enough where I don't
really care it tastes pretty good
there's also a small difference in the
classic legendary Burger in the two
countries the UK uses just regular
cheddar cheese while the US specifically
uses tilamook cheddar tilamook is a
popular creamy based in Oregon I'm not
going to bite into everything here today
because we are going to give some of
this away but if there's anything that
catches my eye particularly then I'll
give it a try we actually have quite a
few exclusives in the UK so I'll start
at this end and work my way down first
off we have cauliflower tacos I think
they are pretty much as the name
suggests it's a taco which is a I think
is a flower tortilla with some pieces of
seasoned cauliflower in there as well as
some SLO some sauce and some jalapenos
next up we've got barbecue chicken this
one really just does what it says on the
tin it's just half of a chicken which
has been grilled and covered in barbecue
sauce it's almost unnerving how
accurately they have halved this
chicken it's literally they've just gone
straight through the middle of it with
like a laser beam and slice the thing
into the next exclusive menu item is
fish and chips you get this a lot you
might have a company which branding wise
seems like it's not from the UK but when
they launch in the UK they feel
compelled to have fish and chips on the
menu I will have to try this one I can't
let them off the hook if they've really
butchered fish and chips although I will
give them again some credit for the fact
that this has been sitting around for a
while and therefore has lost all of the
crisp which I think it once
had it's not too bad I do think had we
eaten this hot and fresh it would have
been a bit crispier you can definitely
see some of the kind of like flakes of
batter which would have crisped up next
up we have the moving mountains Burger
now we don't have the impossible Burger
on the UK menu because as of right now
impossible beef still cannot be sold in
the UK Moving Mountains is a company
which does very similar things it's
making plant-based meat Alternatives
including a beef burger which is
approved for sale in the UK and is on
offer here I mean visually I got to say
the movie mburger does look pretty good
it's got like a nice Brown exterior they
got the kind of like grainy like meat
fibers almost in the middle and it
definitely like looks a bit pink
even I'm quite impressed by that that's
really not bad obviously doesn't have
the exact beef taste that we used to but
there's definitely like a meatiness to
it every Hard Rock Cafe location also
has a local Burger which is inspired by
ingredients found in that area so this
is the London Burger on here you will
find a beef patty with some layers of
roast beef a horseradish Mayo rocket
some tomato and some lettuce now the
London Burger is Loosely inspired by a
British Sunday roast specifically the
roast beef I do think I need to taste
this to uh see if it's giving an
accurate representation of British
Cuisine they've been fairly generous
with the roast beef slices I have to
say
cheers you definitely do get that like
roast beef flavor from these pieces of
beef I think it could maybe have done
with even more horseradish Mayo cuz the
flavor of that is really lovely it's
pretty good whether it's a accurate
representation of London and London
Cuisine I'm going to go with no but is
it a tasty burger kind of yes New York
City City doesn't have a region specific
Burger but they do offer a French dip on
garlic bread Joe made me aware that the
French dip was not created in New York
but rather LA but I can kind of see what
they were going for because roast beef
sandwiches in general are popular here
that includes French dips and they might
have chosen the garlic bread because New
York City has so much Italian and
Italian American culture ingrained in it
I feel like I'm kind of reaching right
now but I'm just trying to make sense of
it all this is the garlic bread that
they speak of um I think we need to have
some words with Hard Rock Cafe what is
the sauce
called bless
you got her got both of them I'm taking
a dip I'm taking a dip you can do it you
can do it this is the coldest aou and
the coldest fridge
dip
this is just not it go somewhere else go
somewhere else Hard Rock Cafe has also
partnered with the greatest footballer
of all time lonel Messi now I'm not sure
if Messi's diet allows him to regularly
eat at Hard Rock Cafe however he's
partnered with them to release two
burgers you can find the messy beef
burger in both the US and the UK but in
the UK we have an exclusive one the
messy chicken burger let's just take a
look and see what we can find so we have
what looks to be maybe like a potato
roll we got some
bacon some
cheese a big grilled chicken breast
there is some sauce on here as
well
mayonnaise as well as tomato and lettuce
if I take a bite out of this do you
think I will gain the footballing
ability of Leonel
Messi whether that is a sandwich fitting
for the goat I'm not sure speaking of
Messi I think now's a great time to quiz
Joe and see if he can pick him out in a
group of photos he is one of the most
famous men in the entire world so it
shouldn't be hard right Joe so one of
these persons is uh Lionel Messi and uh
I don't know which one he is uh well
this guy's from Ted lasso so I'm
assuming it's not him or someone would
have said at some point can you believe
that guy is also a famous soccer player
uh this looks like a person who works in
a cafe so I'm that you tough times for
football players apparently I mean this
just looks like I feel like I've seen
this guy somewhere feel like this guy
works at Insider who's this is this
can't be him this looks like a stock
photo and then this looks like a guy
from like a background extra in The
Matrix so so I'm going to think that
it's this guy oh it's not this guy yeah
this this guy is this super famous
football soccer player so I think I was
right this is shutter stock though that
kind of looks like the Stinger from Al
City
[Laughter]
hey what do you want from me none of
this means anything to
me a legendary Burger in the US contains
1,610 calories now I don't know if they
mean 1,610 calories with the fries or
without so just keep that in mind
according to the FDA that is 81% of my
daily recommended caloric intake here in
the UK the original legendary Burger
contains
1,375 calories which according to FDA
guidelines is around 69% of my daily
recommended allowance a lot of food
items on the Hard Rock menu are actually
super high in calories including the
baby back ribs which clock in at
2,433 calories here in the UK the baby
back ribs contain around
1,796 calories which makes the US
version around 35% more calorific more
detailed nutritional info for Hard Rock
Cafe doesn't seem to be available online
but I did notice this little tiny salt
symbol that was next to a whole bunch of
dishes this indicates that the sodium
content of that item is higher than the
total daily recommended limit which is
2,300 mg there's something about a fudge
brownie with vanilla ice cream that
feels very American food chain in the US
this dessert contains
1,122 Cals I I think it's worth it
though this thing looks really good in
the UK the fudge brownie with ice cream
comes to 2009 calories what we have here
is the takeaway version which I
personally do not think contains 2,000
calories I think what they're referring
to is the in restaurant version which is
an enormous chocolate fudge sunde with
loads of ice cream sauces and More in
front of me now I have a starter of 12
chicken wings with buffalo sauce I have
the main which is the legendary burger
and fries and I have dessert which is an
apple cobbler now I would say this is a
fairly standard dinner I think it would
be on the heavier side for a dinner but
if I was hungry I could definitely
polish off all three courses no problem
however if I ate all of this I would be
consuming
4,819 calories I think those daily
caloric intake values might be outdated
and Vary depending on the person I'm not
a nutritionist I'm just a
girl in the US in order of buffalo wings
a legendary burger and a hot fudge
brownie would cost around
$52.70 $ it looks good just not $20 good
Hard Rock Cafe is a theme restaurant and
I feel like with a theme restaurant also
comes pretty high prices I think that's
because they're kind of tourist trappy
they think people are willing to pay
more because it's an experience and not
just the food in the UK the same meal
would cost you £
4385 which is
$56.64
3 it's kind of a lot of food and as
we've discussed a lot of calories but
also I don't think I'm getting that much
value for my money I feel like even in
London I can find better value elsewhere
and I do think it's kind of being
marketed as kind of like a tourist trap
or maybe kind of a special occasion
treat
meal did you know that the first Hard
Rock Cafe was actually opened in London
it was the hide Park branch and it
opened in 1971 it's pretty rare to come
across a Hard Rock Cafe if you don't
live in like a major city or tourist
destination I think because of that
reason they're not super popular here
even though they are popular in the
sense that we know what it is there are
only 34 locations in the entire us and
six of those are in Florida 18% of the
Hard Rock Cafes in America are in
Florida but this is an international
chain so you can find Hard Rock Cafes in
over 50 countries including Armenia
Nepal Nigeria and Poland Hard Rock Cafe
does have a very dedicated fan base
there's a community of collectors who
will buy and swap commemorative merch
from the different locations including
things like the pins and of course the
iconic t-shirts and jumpers some super
fans even celebrate Hard Rock Milestones
like visiting your 25th location I think
I've got maybe 24 to go same all we have
to do is go to Florida and we can cross
six more off our list they sell normal
American Fair which I can find anywhere
like at a Chili's or an Applebees chains
that are much more available the thing
that makes Hard Rock Cafe special though
isn't the food it's the memorabilia the
first piece of memorabilia donated to
Hard Rock Cafe was Eric Clapton's Lee to
Fender in 1979 since then they have
amassed quite the collection with 86,000
pieces worldwide supposedly it is the
largest private collection of Music
memorabilia in the entire world these
days the memorabilia is still either
donated to them or sometimes purchased
through auctions there are some pretty
cool pieces out there including Elvis
Presley's 24 karat gold leaf piano
handwritten lyrics for John Lennon's
imagine and of course One Direction
iconic phone box which they used in
their album cover
shoot I am so jealous that Harry got to
take a picture with the One Direction
phone booth I don't care if something
good happened to you it should have
happened to me instead I did manage to
get a picture with one of Beyonce's
outfits from her green light music video
it's not as iconic as the One Direction
phone booth but it's something we have a
quote here from one of the Hard Rock
Cafe Founders which we think is quite
interesting it says the Hard Rock Cafe
mayfair's Grace was becoming London's
first classless restaurant at a time
when a baker and a banker could not
commune live shop or Dine together I
think they might be reaching a little
bit here I do think that London in the
70s was kind of in its Punk era I think
social barriers were already being torn
down we'd already had the kind of hippie
movement in the 60s I don't think Hard
Rock Cafe can really claim that they
were the only ones to break down social
barriers and there is nothing more Punk
than the Hard Rock Cafe from calorie
count to portion sizes we wanted to find
the differences between MREs and ration
packs in the us and the UK this is food
[Music]
Wars a US m is manufactured and package
by Warick Americal and so Paco uh and
come in one standard pack size UK MREs
or ration packs as we call them are
produced by vesty foods and come in
three portion sizes the standard portion
is this a 24-hour ration pack you can
also get a smaller version which is a
12-hour russing pack and our biggest
portion is this this this is a 10man
operational pack which contains 10 of
these 24-hour ration packs according to
the defense Logistics agency website a
case of MREs which is 12 Meals weighs
around 22 lb or 9.98 kg so on average 1
meal would be roughly
8316 G the approximate weight of one of
these ration packs is 1.75 kg but we're
going to wait to see if that's
accurate so the weight of our 24hour
rationing pack here in the UK was
actually 1.49 kg this is a bit lower
than the promised 1.75 I don't know if
you're a soldier in the field if this is
actually a positive thing cuz you got
less weight to carry or if you're
actually getting slightly less food than
you were promised in the UK our ration
pack menu number two contains a chili
con caret we're going to compare ours to
the American Chile to see who's getting
more I do think I've lost a little bit
in here and if I were eating this
straight out of the packet maybe tearing
the packet open and getting better
access I could probably get that closer
to uh the 300 mark so here are the
contents of a 24-hour ration pack in the
UK in total we counted 29 edible items
as well as a few extra bits including
tissues sanitary wipes matches and other
stuff like that we counted 11 edible
items in our us ration
pack here are all the military MREs for
the US not available in the UK and here
are all the ration packs in the UK that
you can't find in the US there's
actually very few overlap of specific
meals in US MREs and and the UK ration
packs also depending on which MRE meal
you get uh they contain different
combinations of snacks and sides in both
countries official MREs are not
available for sale directly to Consumers
basically when you get a ration pack in
the UK it will come with a corresponding
menu number the menu number will give
you a rough indication of what you're
going to find inside although there is a
bit of variation so what we've done here
is lay out the breakfast and the main
course options in order of the menus in
the UK we're currently able to get hold
of menus 1 to 10 all right we got the US
MREs I think we got every menu 1 through
24 we're going to go through the Entre
and the breakfasts now I want to point
out that for the US MREs not every
single one came with a definitive
breakfast and some of them just had
something that was fruit or fruit
related which we assumed was supposed to
be eaten first thing in the morning now
all of these can be eaten either hot or
cold I guess ideally you'd have them
heated up we actually got sent this
flameless heating bag instructions for
use this is either going to go really
well or I'm going to give myself and the
food Wars table some chemical bands I'm
going to do a chili because we've
already got a chili opens and I kind of
know what they taste like filter line
only and then leave that for 10 minutes
oh well it
works I hope I've sealed that well
enough cuz that steamed up very quickly
there so while that doesn't S I guess
All That Remains is for me to try the
rest of them St down here remember a
good friend the chili not bad I would
say as average as chili can be
I think honestly I've never been in the
military I haven't done any service but
I used to Camp a lot when I was a kid
and I do remember going on like
sometimes two three week long canoe
trips in Canada couple days in this is
like Gourmet you know what I'm talking
about like your standards change quickly
when you're outside all day it comes
with a cornbread this cornbread muffin
is actually really good let's try with
the
chil so the breakfast that we got for
menu one was pork sausage and beans in a
tomato sauce this this is like kind of
an iconic British meal I can't lie it's
kind of good we're starting off strong I
like that next up we have a pindy Chana
Aloo which seems to be like a potato and
chickp cry and then the final option
from menu one in the UK meatballs and
pasta do I have high or low expectations
for meatballs and pasta yeah I mean I
think my fear was that like pasta
doesn't hold up very well when it's kind
of submerged in a sauce and cooked for a
while and I think that's kind of come
true meatballs are right though menu
number two is shredded beef and barbecue
sauce but also came with seasoned black
beans and tortillas so I mean I don't
know how you would do this out in the
field with no plates and not a table and
then the
beans a military Taco here we go these
beans are Rock Solid the consistency is
a little weird this one is the chicken
and noodles with vegetables and
sauce yeah this this looks like uh like
a can of like Chunky Soup or chunky stew
before you he up this definitely should
be heated up before and this oh my God
this is brutal if you had this and you
couldn't heat it up for some reason this
is very bad the first potential
breakfast the applesauce with raspberry
puree now we're talking
here oh my God that does not taste like
fruit that tastes like pure sugar there
is fruit in it but it tastes more like
like uh fruit flavored soda this will
definitely wake up in the morning then
we're on to menu two and the breakfast
is a raspberry musy with milk now it
says with milk but there is no liquid in
here so I think what they've done is
actually put powdered milk in here and
you add some water and then hopefully
that kind of turns into something
resembling milk it looks very uh chalky
and powdery at the moment without the
water in it it says to add around 100 Ms
of water mix it and then leave it to
stand for a minute or so but yeah I mean
now that's looking a lot more like
musley that's actually not bad I'm quite
impressed by that there is like a
slightly noticeable difference between
that and real milk then the mains for
menu 2 obviously the chili con car which
we opened for the portion sizes section
not the best visuals but it's quite hard
to make a nice looking chili anyway so
it's more about the taste it's not spicy
pretty well seasoned and the menu too
also has a rajma masala the longer I
leave this one I think this is the first
one that has actually like a bit of heat
to it but not unpleasant at all just
like a nice a nice warmth there this HS
close to home spaghetti with beef and
sauce oh and it even came with Italian
bread sticks
what do we think it's not meatballs they
had meatballs we only have meat
sauce red sticks they're a bit dry
they're the most driest thing I've ever
eaten these are so dry it's white
chicken chunks oh no it's
just I just canned white
chicken no i' I'd be so
bummed yeah this is the worst one so we
got a beef taco filling with Santa Fe
rice
um not horrible decent seasoning but
yeah I think what's missing for all
these is cheese they R to Men 3 and we
have our first duplicate item it's
another musle for breakfast now this one
I'm intrigued by one of the main options
in menu 3 steak and vegetables with
dumplings a classic British beef stew is
kind of one of my favorite foods having
said that I've opened this and it looks
and smells like cat food now I've been
eating most of these straight out of the
bag because they've had a kind of
texture which permits that but this one
I think we're going to have to Plate up
this uh apparently is steak and
vegetables with dumplings now I started
this section by saying that all of these
can be eaten hot or cold and I do think
that's true I guess the question is
whether or not all of them should be
eaten hot or cold and I think this one
just immediately from the look of it I
think probably needs to be heaten up
because we've had our uh our first WP
wamp moment of the episode
God that's not good beef strips in a
savory tomato sauce Mar sauce with
meatballs wait so there's no noodles
just sauce and
meatballs oh my goodness look how little
these meatballs are look these little
guys there's no there has no pasta in
here just the meatballs yeah o a
spaghettio level of meat flavor beef
stew now at least this one has noodles
and this one came with a
breakfast that was grape jelly we're
going to chop ahead slightly to menu
eight because that's where I've taken
our hot man from and the alarm has just
gone off which means it's ready to eat
once it's cooked just tear it along here
and then it's at the perfect height that
you can then just also tear this and eat
the whole thing it's changed the
consistency of this a little bit I think
with the steak and vegetables for
example I think that would change the
consistency a lot whereas this has just
made it like a little bit more runny but
not too bad it was very hot but that's
still really good I think this one I do
prefer heated up actually it brings out
a few more of the flavors a little bit
more depth of flavor to it that's really
good and I'm so impressed with this like
heating pad thing the uh the heating pad
as well as just I guess guess warmed up
Meals thumbs up for me so far macaroni
and a beef sauce that's good we got
noodles and the chili oh it's terrible
it doesn't taste like anything
vegetarian taco pasta which is a
vegetable crumble with pasta and taco
style
sauce is this supposed to be zapple
sauce who doesn't love a little
applesauce again wow super sweet but
sugar not high fructose corn soups
that's a plus and the last item for menu
3 is a beef burrito Style filling with
rice sadly this does not come with any
tortillas so you can't make an actual
burrito with it it's a little bit more
spiced than anything else that I've had
so far the texture of the rice would be
improved by heating this one up cuz the
rice is still like a little bit Al Dente
elbow macaroni and tomato sauce granted
I mean I know I got to heat them up yeah
this one's all right uh mango peach
applesauce liking the applesauce this
would be considered I guess a breakfast
or it's fruity so maybe this you would
have first thing in the day oh yeah oh
this is really good next up we got got
menu four and we're starting with an all
day breakfast apparently it differs from
the sausage and beans because this
contains some omelette as well as some
bacon pieces I think my only criticism
of this is that the sauce that they put
the beans in is like exceptionally sweet
carrying on through menu four we have a
pasta bnes M I have a similar concern to
the meatballs and pasta I think that is
like roughly the color that you want
your bolog sauce to look like I think
when I looked at this one I was
expecting worse again like the vibe I'm
getting particularly from the pasta
dishes is very that tinned pasta Vibe
like a tinned bnise and the last menu
for item is a chicken curry with
potatoes and rice there's actual like
decent Siz pieces of what I hope is
chicken less flavorful than some of the
other ones I want to try heating some of
these up you do this then you put your M
inside sorry you can't tell adding water
to this here we go real exciting stuff
here in the studio while we're moving on
so we got one two three heating up the
staff was able to make this thing work I
was not I don't know why but moving on
we have a cheese tortillini and a tomato
sauce oh yeah look at this I got the
whole a whole Toral right there then
we're on to menu five and we're starting
off with another musle it's the third
musy we've had in five meals the
variation I think is going to start to
kind of run dry speaking of a lack of
variation meal 5 also has another pasta
bolones the different option for meal 5
is a sweet and sour chicken with rice
good color on it nice uh familiar orange
color there pineapple this and water
chestnuts I'm kind of impressed this is
pretty good I'd say this leans more on
the balance of sweet rather than sweet
and sour I think with the water chestnut
and also the kind of like pineapple
chunks there's still some things in
there with bites which I appreciate
creamy spinach fetuccini with egg
noodles spinach and mushroom in a cream
sauce
oh it feels like they're going a
little I don't say overboard cuz I
figured you got have like a variety of
meals but doesn't like a fetuccini with
mushrooms and a cream sauce like after
after a long day of hauling stuff around
and soldiering and just exhausting job
and carrying all the stuff and just
being like ah let's kick back with some
spinach mushrooms and a cream sauce like
the most colorful one so far I don't
feel great I do not feel good next up is
menu six which we've actually covered
all of already starts with an all day
breakfast which I've had then moves on
to a another pasta bones which I've also
had and finishes with my old friend
steak vegetables with dumplings which I
will absolutely not be trying again this
should be the Mexican style chicken stew
oh and then they're saying there's
another tear here to remove the M very
smart so you got a second spot to tear
this is really smart second spot to tear
so it's easier just to
grab the M
out all right so the package is hot so
feels like this is much I kind of
smooshing around a little bit so they
are still flimsy tortillas but looks
like they're Chipotle flavored not as
gelatinous I
guess definitely better heated up yeah I
like this this pretty good next up is
menu 7 which I don't know if this was
deliberate or not but appears to be like
a fully vegetarian menu for starters we
have a vegetarian all day breakfast I
think the main difference is that
they've subbed out the meat sausages for
vegetarian sausages it's another one
that seems to be like mostly beans it
seems very fitting that the British army
is powered by baked
beans makes you proud to be British it's
got the same issue as before that the
beans are just like I think too sweet
one of the main course options in menu 7
is the rashma Masala with rice which I
have again also had but one that I have
not had is a vegetable and chickpea
Biryani I like a biriani for those who
don't know it's just
like various things sometimes meat in
this case vegetables cooked down with
rice and a bunch of Indian spices I've
had much better burani in the past I'm
sure there are lots of people watching
at home and recoiling in horror at the
thought of this being a Biryani but it's
okay and I think on the whole vegetarian
menu pretty good moving on we have the
chicken burrito bowl which comes in a
bag and not a bowl sure a lot of this
just like I know we got some heated up
so you can see the difference when it's
not heated up it's just this weird gel
Cube and that comes with what
essentially would be considered a
breakfast I guess Apple pieces and a
spiced sauce so the entree appears to be
a maple flavored pork sausage patty okay
so just one block of
yep
ah it is of course just this it's like a
cliff bar but pork not good really weird
it tastes uh surprisingly Bland a hash
brown potato with bacon pepper and
onions ooh no this is the most cat Foody
looking one menu 8 is another duplicate
one we start with another all day
breakfast then there's another chili con
carne which I've actually already heat
up and eaten and we have another beef
burrito style filling with rice a cooked
beef ravioli once again it like heated
the bottom of it so you still got to
kind of still got to massage it a little
bit like this this side is heated and
then this middle part didn't get heated
it also came with tortillas which is
funny this what this looks like and it
looks gross menu 9 starts with more musy
then moves to a new dish which is
sausage casserole this is another like
classic British dish a sausage cassero
slow cooked stewed sausages with tomato
potatoes other vegetables on the whole
the sausages have actually been like
surprisingly good it might just be
because I quite like those slightly
cheap like prepackaged sausages and then
for your other main course we have
another pindy Chana Aloo this one
another hot one oh it's just it's just
going to be a Patty
oh it has a sauce apparently it's
grilled jalapeno pepper jack flavored
comes L Gren
potatoes Len potatoes what do you think
of that this looks really rough Italian
sausage with peppers onions and a
marinara sauce yeah okay menu number 21
should be lemon pepper tuna or tuna
chunks in a bag we've just been informed
that this bag actually says white
chicken chunks sell before there is a
lemon pepper tuna that we don't have and
finally last but not least we have menu
10 which starts with an instant porridge
the cooking instructions actually
specify that you need to put boiling
water in it leave it for 3 minutes to
soak and then eat it whereas all the
other ones are technically able to be
eaten cold menu 10 has a couple of mains
one of which is another beef burrito
style filling with rice and our final
main course is Hunter's chicken it's
another it's another plate one uh which
I don't think is a compliment doesn't
look great does it um this is Hunter's
chicken traditionally this is chicken
breast with some bacon some cheese some
barbecue sauce I think bits of chicken
in here although I'm kind of struggling
to
see
where I think it's these like small bits
rather than like a chicken breast no no
that was pretty bad beef goulash beef
with brown rice spinach carrots tomatoes
and smoked paprika a pepperoni pizza and
cheese
slice Army
pizza oh God that's so bad this has been
brutal I don't know what it is about
this food like yes some things tasted
bad but most things just just tasted
okay but I have a headache and my
stomach doesn't feel good I noticed
there's a lot of sodium in these so that
might have something to do with it
tortillas came with this one the
Southwest style beef and black beans
with sauce again we very few breakfasts
but this one is mixed fruit which
appears to be there's some chunks in
there so you got a bag of mixed fruit on
top of the mains and breakfast options
you also get a dessert in a British
ration pack the options we got today
included a chocolate brownie a cinnamon
cake a vanilla cake a chocolate cake or
an orange cake the US MREs have have an
assortment of desserts which looks all
right muffin tops cookies puddings cakes
a bun a toaster pastry cookies and
cobblers I'll try a couple of these I
want to try the brownie because it's
packaged differently to the others and
because I like brownie it looks a little
bit more cakey than brownish but uh
we'll see n that's so dry starting down
here get a maple muffin top or a
chocolate banana nut muffin top uh three
different types of cookies you get a
oatmeal chocolate chip cookie chocolate
chip cookie and oatmeal cookie that's
funny and actually I think about it
we've got patriotic sugar cookies could
be in the cookie category the packaging
was different so I separated them but
I'm curious a patriotic sugar cookie
looks like oh no nothing these look like
broken up Girl Scout cookies is that a
rocket what is that I don't know what
that is you know what that is oh like oh
my God turn it around turn it upside
down ah it's cele liberity Tor oh it's a
bunch of different ones but they're all
broken up oh well these are pretty good
then I wanted to try one of the cake
options actually probably the cinnamon
that appeals to me the most so I mean
this looks
better it could be again slightly more
moist but it's got a pretty nice texture
to it there's definitely a cinnamon
flavor there in terms of like shelf
stable baked goods this is a much better
refer than the brownie was this is
actually like perfectly edible have an
assortment of pound cakes applesauce
pound cake lemon poppy seed pound cake
vanilla pound cake marel pound cake uh
cinnamon
bun
and a toaster pastry that just feels
completely destroyed in here so I don't
know what toaster using on the field but
all right and last this package that
looks like all the other ones is a
cherry blueberry cobbler I think this
just be fine oh that's colorful but it
looks like whole thing like jelly every
ration pack in the UK also comes with
four to five snack options which we've
taken all the ones we got from menus 1
to 10 and laid them out here snacks our
us MREs come with a lot of snacks
usually find three or four of these in
each M and various combinations so here
we have a mixed fruit snack which is
like a fruit puree in one of these handy
little pouches first of all I mean how
bright do these look just compared to
all the packs we been dealing with this
whole video like I'm looking at these
I'm almost want to turn the saturation
down peppermint candy rings and then you
got M&M's twizz or nibs more M&M's
Skittles Skittles racist pieces very
nice thank you there are a few different
peanut options on the menus in the UK
starting with barbecue peanuts some
chili peanuts and the classic salted
peanuts dried fruit dried
cranberries raisins and a trail mix that
has a nut raisin mix for the trail here
we have cheddar cheese flavor spread in
the UK if you're having cheese cheese
you have like cheese and crackers so I
feel like maybe this is supposed to be
enjoyed with some of these crackers down
this end down here three different types
of energy bars you can get I've never
heard of the brand First Strike not sure
if that is a brand that exists outside
the military but you can get an apple
cinnamon chocolate or cran raspberry
energy bar oh jeez look at this
thing not a bunch of
junk it tastes okay next we have a a
fruit Flapjack Flapjack in the UK is a
mixture of Oats syrup butter and often
raisins which are kind of like packed
together to make a nice nutritious sweet
treat this is an oatmeal block I'm not
really sure what this is I'm actually
going to open this one just out of
curiosity more than anything looks like
a sort of shortbread biscuit on the
outside yeah somewhere between like a
digested biscuit and like a Rusk which
for the
uninitiated is like I think an OTE
biscuit SK that's basically made for
babies I feel like I used to steal rusks
from my baby sister when she was little
sorry Annie trail mix granola nuts you
got it um packages of either dry roasted
nuts man they really suck this thing dry
look at that same with this one the uh
smoked almonds and jalapeno cashews
recovery trail mix with pretzels
granola and this trail mix it has beef
jerky in it want to Mainline your jerky
US government has you covered beef
sticks here we have a sachet of peanut
butter we have three different types of
jam that we found we have apricot we
have Plum and we have strawberry jam
this is an exotic fruits nouar bar here
we have a sesame bar which is basically
just sesame seeds held together with
melted sugar apricot oat biscuits a
tropical fruit and nut mix as well as
just nuts and just fruit cheese filed
cracker pepperoni
flavor uh cheese filled pretzel cheddar
flavor pretzel nuggets barbecue corn
nuggets barbecue flavored corn kernel so
like corn nuts right baked snack
crackers cheddar flavor and the protein
Puffs ring-shaped barbecue I feel like
if you get these ones you've done quite
well these sound fancy we have chocolate
orange mini cookies and coconut biscuit
bites they sound like a more Gourmet
approach to a a Russian pack snack and
to the breads spreads we'll call it
multi- grain bread
white wheat snack bread wheat snack
bread I mean how good are the shots we
have to get of these everything looks
the same and then this one Italian bread
bloby blob got it okay great you have a
vegetable cracker or a regular cracker
what do you want to put on those breads
or crackers you got chunky peanut butter
peanut butter chocolate peanut spread
cheese spread cheese spread with
jalapenos cheese spread with bacon here
we have cheese and oat biscuits which I
think are probably designed like I say
to be eaten with the cheesy spread next
up our biscuit Browns I wasn't sure what
I B Brown was and after tasting it I'm
still kind of equally unsure it's like a
sort of brand like wheaty cracker type
thing for the fruit you got apple jelly
strawberry jam and know there's a grape
jelly from earlier I don't know where it
went but it looks exactly like this
package and finally we have a cookies
and cream bar that's not what I was
expecting at all when you hear cookies
and cream I'm right in thinking that you
expect Oreo right whereas this is more
like a like a rice krispy type of treat
doesn't smell of Oreo at all it
literally smells of like like a Rice
Krispy treat maybe dark chocolate
doesn't taste great either the US MREs
have an assortment of different drinks
both I guess regular temperature and
warm so the first thing I want to do
before we get into that is point out
that we have four different in the
middle here coffee drinks hot drinks you
want to as you have it this is a french
vanilla cappuccino and I want to make it
real quick we saw how we heated up the
drinks before so here also comes with a
hot beverage bag pre- added the water so
now I'm going to go ahead
put tow in
here this looks all right mix it up a
little B I have
me
[Applause]
cappuccino it smells like when the VCR
gets really hot you watch like three
movies in a row now we're on to the
drink options which again I think you
get four of in a 24-hour British ration
pack these all come in the form of
powders which you mix with water and
then consume they're also split into
four different categories we have just a
standard drink powder we have an energy
drink powder a fortified energy drink
powder and we have an isotonic drink
powder having quickly scanned the
ingredients of both of these I'm
actually not sure what the difference is
between say an energy drink powder and a
standard fruit flavor powder there's no
caffeine in the Energy powders for
example I think most of the energy is
coming from the sugar content in these
while that's cooking let's see what
other drinks we
have we got orange lemon lime and grape
that's definitely not grape colored it
says grape on
here I think it tastes like grape but
also cuz it's blue I'm thinking blue
raspberry while my coffee is cooking we
also have different coffee flavors I get
a chocolate hazelnut protein drink Irish
cream cappuccino chocolate protein drink
regardless of the type of drink powder
that you're getting they do come in a
bunch of different flavor options I'm
not sure if any of these particularly
appeal to me I'll try the Tutti Frutti
one I feel like of all of these sounds
pretty fun yeah I was really hoping that
the color would be like a bright blue or
pink or something but just
normal it's unlocking some kind of like
repressed alcohol memory I think I'm
fairly sure I've drunk a a cocktail to
the point of Oblivion that tasted pretty
much like this so this is my French
vanilla
coffee oh yeah not recognizing a lot of
these
words but yeah this is nice and the last
thing we have here are beverage based
powders uh so these had electrolytes in
them it's like energy drinks almost and
then these I think are just uh these
have lots of sugar so we have lemon lime
orange and tropical punch and then this
little stick beverage based orange type
3 finally every ration pack in the UK
also contains a bag of common
items
we'll start down this end where we have
some matches then we have some water
purification tablets I think there are
six of these in here actually and
according to this you can purify a liter
of water per tablet so that's pretty
good I like that this is in the
essential items thing we have some hot
sauce we have some tissues as well as
two alcohol-free hand wipes then you
have two tea bags two sachet of instant
coffee four saet of Beverage Whitener I
think again this might be something
along the lines of they can't legally
call this powdered milk but it is
effectively a powdered milk substitute
and four saet of sugar our us MREs have
these following accessories first of all
over here you've seen it a few times
this episode the
heating thing the heating bags to heat
up your food and your drinks saw this
the whole time the spoon every M comes
with the spoon now as you notice I had a
difficult time kind of cutting into some
stuff and I thought why don't they have
anything like a knife in here of course
they have a knife they're soldiers they
have pocket knives
uh they come with a um concentrated
beverage base this one is cranberry
grape over here is the coffee zone for
the most part bills brewed freeze dried
coffee you can do add of two hot or cold
water 6 o right here and you have your
choice of either Splenda of sugar salt
if you need more sodium on your food
this is a coffee creamer each pack of
accessory comes with two pieces of gum
these are waterproof matches spice up
that food a little bit a little bit of
Tabasco little Tabasco guy look at a
little guy
guy right a moist tiet and regular
napkins in the US EMES were first
introduced in the 1980s and were
designed to be lightweight portable and
self-contained meals that didn't require
cooking or Refrigeration they were also
intended to provide the necessary
nutrition for soldiers in the field
early iterations of British ration packs
actually used cans it wasn't until the
1990s that these were replaced with
pouches each M typically contains around
1200 to 1300 calories with balanced
nutrition essential to supporting the
demands placed on soldiers during
military operations each m is said to
have approximately 170 G of
carbohydrates 45 g of protein and 50 g
of fat as we've said a British ration
pack is usually designed for 24 hours
worth of nutrition whereas it seems as
if the American ones are not we can
assume this because the average
nutritional value of an entire British
russan pack is somewhere between 3,800
and 4200 calories and here's a chili
meal from before we're going to go
through its specific nutrition now I
want to point out that the bag didn't
have anything on it so I am learning
about the nutrition of these in real
time the chili with the beans one
serving size all this is 260 calories
and this single serving of cornbread
with your chili also 260 calories your
vegetable cracker is going to be 170
calories and your cheesy spread is 120
calories then the cheese filed crackers
that the pepperoni pizza flavor 240
calories for this one and if you going
be sipping on your lemon lime flavored
nonf fruit juice juice that's going to
be 130 calories for the whole beverage a
grand total of this many calories we've
selected some items which seem to match
up roughly with what you'd expect to
find in a US M here we have the chili
con carne main we've got some crackers
with the cheese spread some peanut
butter and a fruit flavored drink the
total calories for these items comes to
1,37 9 the FDA recommends that adults
consume around 75 to 90 Mig of vitamin C
per day just two of these drink saet is
more than enough vitamin C for that
intake we are not getting scurvy anymore
we learned our lessons back in the Navy
days although it's also worth noting the
amount of sugar that is in one of these
in a 45 G sachche of mango and passion
fruit drink you will find 40.5 gr of
sugar that's 81% of your daily
recommended intake just in one of
these let's take a look at the
ingredients of the chili con carne in
the UK be
red kidney beans tomato puree water
onion red and green peppers wheat flour
calcium carbonate iron thamin and
nicotinamide modified May starch salt
spices spice extracts calcium carbonate
and smoke flavor the ingredients in here
are actually all pretty natural without
any real artificial preservatives our
eyebrows were raised when we saw
nicotinamide in the wheat flour
thankfully it's not some kind of
nicotine it's just another type of
vitamin B3 AKA niin this chili with
beans contains all this uh looks like
mostly normal stuff until you get the
bottom of the list there ethylated monod
diglycerides I have no idea what that is
I don't think we've ever had that in
food Wars before so uh if someone in
editing can go ahead and say what it's
used for these have a minimum shelf life
of 3 years depending on storage
conditions uh the storage conditions for
these MREs I'm assuming were room
temperature the whole time so I'm
feeling prettyy confident these are all
uh not expired similarly I have a shelf
life of around 3 years and after that
it's down to the temperature at which
they're stored for example this chili
was made in December 2021 and apparently
is shelf stable until around 2025 and
how can these meals have such a long
shelf life you ask according to the USDA
M are shelf stable because they have
been commercially sterilized by heat in
a sealed container to destroy bacteria
that can make it unsafe or spoil the
food like food in metal cans MREs can be
kept for a long time but but not
indefinitely the shelf life of MREs and
ration packs is pretty directly related
to the temperature at which they're
stored the cooler the storage
temperature the longer their last
rations in a desert temperature might
only last a few months whereas rations
at room temperature or colder climates
can be good up to 5 years we're filming
this towards the end of 2023 which means
that our chili con carne for example is
already around 2 years old I've got to
say I don't feel great after eating them
however I do think that's probably more
due to the quantity that I've eaten
rather than due to the storage quality
of these since 1981 the US menu has
changed about five times improving the
quality and the taste it also has
expanded the menu variety and now
includes vegetarian kosher and Hal
options there also aren't many changes
in the UK however there was a recent
controversial change chocolate bars were
taken away from British troops serving
in Iraq and Afghanistan because they
kept melting in the desert heat they
were replaced with a much less popular
Peanut Butter I can see how people would
be annoyed about that from portion sizes
to exclusive flavors we wanted to find
out all the differences between Prime in
the US and the UK this is food
Wars let's start with prime hydration in
the UK it comes in a 500 mill bottle you
can either buy this as a single bottle
or as part of a 12pack in the US our
hydration also comes in one size the
16.9 fluid ounce bottle or 500 mL you
can get an options of one bottle an
eight pack which you did not get sorry
the 12pack and a 15pack variety we also
have Prime energy which in the UK comes
in a 330 ml can just like Prime
hydration this either comes as a single
can or as part of a 12-pack in the US
Prime energy is a 12 flu ounce can or
355 ml and it comes in a single can the
12pack and a 24 pack in the US our
biggest Prime hydration single item by
volume is this the 15 drink variety pack
total fluid volume
23.6 fluid ounces or 7500 M our larger
size is a 12pack of bottles which adds
up to 6 L of prime but that's still 20%
less than the biggest size in America
and if we go on energy
drink 24 cans of these energy drinks
this is 288 FL ounces or
8520 ml our biggest Prime energy item is
again the 12pack but remember the our
cans are slightly smaller than America's
a 12pack of Prime energy in the UK adds
up to 3,960 ml that's
53.5% smaller than the biggest size in
America here are almost all of the
exclusive Prime products you can get in
the US you can't get in the UK and here
are all the prime drinks you'll find in
the UK but not in the US there aren't
any sorry guys there are currently seven
flavors of prime hydration available in
the UK however all of them are available
in the US as well so none of them are
actually exclusive that said there are
some subtle differences in ingredients
when it's compared to the US and also
I've never had prime before so I want to
try all of these give you my thoughts
and maybe rank them as well here are
currently three of the four Prime
hydration drinks you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK so we got the
lemonade we got orange we have this LA
Dodgers flavor that might be just
specific to Los Angeles and there's a
grape flavor couldn't get my hands on
and here are all the other flavors you
get in the US we's start down here lemon
lime I mean this is they're just going
into after Gatorade on this one wasn't
it the first Gatorade flavor lemon lime
really sweet wow that's really sweet ice
pop but also this looks like they have
different names but I grew up calling
them Bomb Pops I feel like I'm really
tasting the Cherry in this one I think
everyone who's tried these has said it
these are very sweet but I I'm kind of
surprised it's marketed towards kids
another thing I wanted to point out is
that I was able to find ice Pop flavors
both in the UK version and the US
version we're going to get more into
ingredients a little bit later on but
I'll do a very quick taste to see if
there's any notable differences we'll
start with the UK one and then we'll try
The American version the flavors are
broadly the same but the way that this
one kind of like hits your taste buds is
very different and it's really weird
when you consume a drink obviously like
you want to feel like your thirst has
been
quenched you take a sip and there's
something in here that's like actually
kind of like drying my mouth out almost
I think if I had to pick which one to
prefer it is going to be the UK's and
I'm not just saying that from bias
tropical
punch what
the all right well that's pretty
embarrassing hope nobody's watching
this I do like that and no no kidding
they're getting progressively better as
we go through them Can't Screw Up orange
M yeah this might be my favorite one
this is really good and this doesn't
feel as sweet as the other ones or am I
just getting used to it like like how
your eyes adjust to the dark I think my
tongue's adjusting to the sweetness to
of the many sports teams in the world
that have some sort of deal with prime
LA Dodgers is one of them yeah I'm seen
people on eBay bidding a lot for these
so straight up I don't know if flavor
this is but it's good do you want to try
it my lips did touch it is it too weird
I mean we have a professional
relationship oh my is so sweet oh no
I've gotten used to it there a good
lemonade as far as lemon flavored not
carbonated beverage pretty good I was
also able to get my hands on one of the
American exclusives the lemonade flavor
I'm interested to try this because the
US and UK do have slightly differing
ideas of what lemonade is obviously in
the UK we consider generally lemonade to
be like a carbonated clear beverage like
a Sprite whereas in America it's usually
just kind of like lemon juice sugar and
water combined so it does taste a bit
like you've let like a a Sprite kind of
go flat you can probably keep this one
for the time being guys glow Berry it is
supposed to glow in the dark the the
label not the
beverage what the hell yeah I think
that's the worst one that's really weird
metam moon what is the vibe of this what
about this says like oh that's so
refreshing this tastes the way uh
sunblock smells watermelon right back to
things I've heard of no this tastes
exactly like gum Bubblicious like one of
those one of those like really fruity
ones yeah yeah we're going to start down
this end with glow Berry Flavor now I
did have to Google this to see if
glowberries were an actual Berry or not
as far as I can tell they are not I
think it generally refers to a berry
flavor and also the fact that the bottle
is supposed to glow in the dark I think
we should put that to the test Charlie
Hit the
lights not really glowing is it
my first taste of prime and it's not
blown my socks off to say it's just a
very artificial Berry flavor got a bit a
Tang to it next up we've got strawberry
watermelon
wow I like that the flavor I get from
that is almost more like a Kind of Blue
Powerade type flavor according to the
label the ice pot flavor is supposed to
taste like cherry lime and blue
raspberry yeah I mean so far the vibe
I'm getting is that they just taste kind
of artificial fruit but I think in terms
of like balancing the flavors this one's
done a pretty good job so far maybe the
most uh delicately balanced flavor of
the lot next up we've got meta Moon
obviously I don't know what the moon
tastes like and I don't know what the
meta tastes like right now either if
there were a food Wars meta yellow
number five would be S tier right
now label just says this is candy
flavored which doesn't fill me with
confidence cuz like which candy tastes
like M Zucker
bag oh it doesn't taste like it smells
no
like at least these ones have had like a
fairly identifiable fruity flavor
whereas this one is just kind of like
generic sweet thing then we're on to
blue raspberry and one thing that's
immediately stuck out to me is the color
I think I was actually expecting this to
be like a more bright blue color it's
actually just kind of white it's quite a
gentle blue raspberry I want a bit more
acidity from that I think but it goes
down very smoothly I do feel like I'm
giving Prime way too much credit here
I'm swilling it around in a glass like
I'm a smellier got to let it
breathe yeah maybe if we had a decanter
I could pour it out let it breathe a
little bit drinking too much prime I'm
going to be hydrated as hell getting
hopped up on Prime I need to go do like
a celebrity boxing match or something
you enjy celebrity boxing let's make
that happen yeah Joe you down you and me
in the ring the full 12 rounds I
actually don't know who' win that who
the fight between me and Joe you back me
Charlie backs me Harry's Vibe is very
like they really like always just like
calm and reserved or whatever but that
kind of like that sarcas
that they have over there to me says
that like something's going on
underneath the surface that they're
suppressing so Harry St the type of guy
that if he got like into a fight fight
he would like just like black out and
then come to at like in the middle of
the field at midnight with a shovel
covered in blood with a corpse in his
trunk I'll box him as long as it's
supervised moving swiftly on from M
fighting next up we've got tropical
punch
Prime woo so while I was out in the US
recently I was able to try Hawaiian
Punch and that's basically exactly what
I'm getting from this and then finally
we've got the lemon lime flavor of all
of these flavors this is the one that
tastes the most like it supposed to if I
had to rank them I think I'd do it in
the following order I think my least
favorite probably metam moon right in
the middle here metam moon is down there
I think with ice pop they've just tried
to combine a bunch of flavors that don't
necessarily work together very well so I
think it's actually going to be my
second to last I think blue raspberry is
going to come next for me and they lose
points cuz I didn't even try and color
it I think next is going to be glow
Berry the bottle didn't really glow so
maybe uh leave it in the sun for a bit
longer if you're going to try that at
home I think next up we're going to have
tropical punch my number two is lemon
lime which means that my number one
strawberry watermelon my favorite is the
orange in second place I like the
Dodgers flavor actually I think about it
I'm going to go here yeah lemon is good
and from here on ice pop H I mean yeah
lemon lime these these were all like I'd
grab any one of these these three I say
ski
a little bit of flavor tweaking or
balancing might go a long way I think
with some of these you wanted like maybe
a bit more Tang to them bit more acidity
maybe dial back the sweetness on one or
two as well I don't know if I would
necessarily pick a prime over a classic
energy drink like a power aid but I do
think in general if I wanted a sports
drink and I went into a store and this
was all they had I think I'd still be
happy to buy one but they're all fine
and they kind of do that same job next
up let's take a look at Prime energy now
while the prime hydration drinks are
similar to maybe like a Power Aid these
are much more similar to a classic
energy drink like a Red Bull there is
one exclusive energy drink flavor in the
US you can't get in the UK it is the
original that just was announced this
week couldn't get it anyway here are the
rest yes the UK also has them most of
them are similar to The hydration
flavors but there is a new one orange
mango I'm a bit apprehensive about
trying these cuz I don't drink energy
drinks I don't even drink coffee I only
drink tea and I think one of these
contains about as much caffeine as three
cups of tea so we'll start with ice pop
chin chin
I think that does mirror the flavor of
the hydration drink pretty closely but I
will say tastes better than like a
standard Red Bull flavor strawberry
watermelon I think there might be a
theme here they just kind of taste like
fizzy versions of that here's the new
one orange mango I get mostly mango I'm
not getting much Orange from that yeah
not far off like a Rubicon tropical
punch is up next yeah I think that one's
actually improved by becoming an energy
drink lemon lime you could give me a
glass of that and a glass of Sprite and
I'd struggle to tell the difference I
think cuz it is just again like a
carbonated lemon and lime beverage blue
raspberry I actually think for a few of
these just carbonating them has actually
made them better I think notably that
was the case with the tropical punch and
also to a degree I think blue raspberry
one I could not get for time of filming
this was the ice pop strawberry
watermelon
though it's like sweet and tart orange
mango uh somehow worse uh-oh so far not
good trpical punch okay
yeah it SMS good lemon lime oh yeah it's
pretty good too kind of spr blue
raspberry
ooh n yeah it's also like a tart flavor
to it that not that end so I think I'm
going to rank it like this favorite was
lemon lime really enjoyed the fruit
punch blue raspberries like in the
middle and then these two I wouldn't get
I guess wow apparently the strawberry
watermelon flavor I'm just not digging
now for the orange mango which was the
worst something about it just tastes
like an armpit ice pop did not like that
one I'm afraid orange mango fine but a
bit too artificial and there are I think
better like fizzy mango drinks out there
in the UK tropical punch and blue
raspberry were both improved I think by
making them fizzy but I think just in
terms of like Flavor balance strawberry
watermelon and
feed one thing I will say about Prime
energy is that so far when I've been
tasting these I feel like on the very
rare occasions when I drink like a Red
Bull or a monster they have kind of like
a very distinct flavor to them and even
if you add flavorings to that it's hard
to mask it completely whereas I don't
really get like a kind of distinct
energy drink flavor throughout all of
these most of them actually do just kind
of taste like fizzy versions of the
hydration drink I think it's actually
quite impressive I think you probably
could drink them almost as a soda I
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing I do think there's still some
room for improvement with the flavors
themselves I think particularly down
this end of course but in general I
think theyve done a pretty good job with
the flavors one product that we have
exclusively here in the US are these
Prime hydration plus sticks these are
like the hydration flavors we have but
in powder form I think you can get it in
almost every single flavor I got two
four six of the crowd got six
sticks
okay I mean it looks lemon lemy too I
guess probably you're supposed to Shake
It Up In This Way do a water bottle in a
cup cuz like look it's all like globula
at the top here H very strong think I
could have cut it with more water but oh
God yeah it's pretty close I mean this
is obviously stronger because it's not
as much water sadly the prime hydration
Plus saet have not hit UK shelves just
yet although I can't say I'm too mad
about that I feel like just buy the
drink it's
fine the price of prime can vary wildly
depending on where or when you were
looking on the official UK website a
12-pack of prime hydration sells for
£24.99 that's around
$31.88 the per buffle cost on the
website therefore is just over2 in the
US that same pack is $29 .999 or £
2356 so not much of a price difference
if you're not aware Prime is a brand of
hydration and energy drinks promoted by
the influencers Logan Paul and KSI the
two have amassed a huge fan base online
through various Ventures on YouTube and
podcasting music and even wrestling the
prime is manufactured by Congo Brands a
company based out of Louisville Kentucky
Paul and KSI are the primary spokes
people for the brand when Prime launched
over a year ago with KSI and Logan Paul
putting their celebrity w behind the
promotion of the brand it was a huge
success however due to the popularity of
the drink a huge reselling Market has
emerged Prime came to the UK in June
2022 and was an immediate smash hit on
release Brit saw teenagers queuing up
outside supermarkets all morning to try
and get their hands on some places like
Asda sold out so quickly that they had
to implement a three bottle per customer
limit convenience stores realized they
could buy Prime in bulk and flip
individual bottles for a huge markup
some such as the Tik Tok famous wakey
wines achieved infamy when they were
caught selling bottles or cans for as
much as £1 each KSI even had to step in
at one point and scold resellers saying
that it was not ethical I wasn't as bad
over here it did fly off the shelves for
a little bit but I think it might have
something to do with the resale value of
these online was pretty good I've never
seen anyone drinking it and to be honest
I got everything at Target and online
kind of no problem now currently the LA
Dodgers limited edition bottles are
pretty pricey on eBay I'm assuming once
again that has more to do with its
scarcity than its taste even now as we f
film this in October 2023 the prime
Market hasn't exactly calmed all the way
down for some of the more standard
flavors the supply has now caught up
with demand and you're able to find them
in most supermarkets for the standard
retail price for example I was able to
find the bottle of strawberry watermelon
in Tesco for just £2 however for some of
the more exotic flavors the only places
you can find them are specialist candy
shops or Niche resellers the only place
I could find my bottle of glow Berry was
one of those weird American candy stores
which plagues Central London this one
bottle cost me £18
I wouldn't have paid 8 for bottle of
prime but you did expens it so you
didn't pay for it either what is the
most I would realistically pay for a
bottle of prime hydration I don't know
five bucks you think five is high how
much would you pay I've just been
informed $5 is too high 15 you can't get
anything for 150 what are you talking
about fine I would pay as much as
Gatorade and Power Aid and all the other
AIDS are for this it's hard to find
empirical evidence as to whether or not
the craze around Prime has kind of died
down but just from an do evence I really
don't think it has even when I was out
buying the prime for this episode I
would see kids in the stores just taking
selfies with bottles of prime like it
was a celebity I think due to the
scarcity and the demand it's almost
become like a status symbol among
certain generations of kids it's a race
to see who can get the new flavors of
prime the fastest people will I guess
empty them out and just use them as like
water bottles when they go to school and
again it's just kind of like a way to
flex on your peers besides converting
their massive fan bases into loyal
customers KSI and Logan Paul have also
been able to translate this into
commercial partnersh ship Prime is now
an official drink supplier of the UFC
the LA Dodgers and Arsenal of which I
believe KSI is a fan and they're also
the official sports drink partners of FC
Barcelona and FC Bayern Munich we've
seen other influencers capitalize on
their success in the food and beverage
Space Mr Beast of course has Beast
burger and his chocolate bars Feast
tables Emma Chamberlain has her coffee
brand Chamberlain coffee now according
to Paul in the first year the brand has
cleared 250 million in retail sales
goodness here are all the ingredients
for a prime hydration ice pot flavor in
the UK these are the US hydration Ice
Pop ingredients the ingredients are
pretty similar overall the UK has
slightly more coconut water 10.5%
compared to America's 10% but ours is
actually reconstituted from a powder
whereas America's is from concentrate
Prime hydration in both countries boasts
zero added sugar but does contain
artificial sweeteners sucos and asil
flame no that's not it a asame k or a k
according to the Center for Science in
the public interest a k raises health
issues such as cancer hormone disruption
and potential pregnancy risks per health
line there is also evidence suggesting
that aceto acetamide the compound formed
in the body during the breakdown of AK
may result in thyroid damage in lab
animals ironically enough the lack of
sugar may be an issue for the very
purpose of prime hydration electrolytes
play a crucial role in making sure your
body functions properly when when you
exercise or play hard you sweat you lose
not just water but you also lose
important electrolytes electrolytes are
key to hydration and Prime does contain
electrolytes like magnesium and
potassium but the low amount of glucose
May impair your body from properly
absorbing the electrolytes as glucose is
useful in transporting them to your
cells typically you don't need glucose
to absorb electrolytes but it does help
Prime energy is currently in hot water
with the media as well as the US
government because of its perceived
excessive levels of caffeine here in the
UK our Prime energy cans contain 140 Mig
of caffeine to put that into perspective
a grande coffee from Starbucks contains
around 136 energy cans in the US however
contain 200 Mig of caffeine which is a
42.9% increase from the UK can because
of this Prime is currently experiencing
a significant amount of backlash
resulting in some shops actually pulling
it from shelves in order to protect
kids' Health in July of this year
Senator Chuck Schumer called for an FDA
probe of prime and said it was a
cauldron of caffeine that posed serious
health concerns for kids One Prime
energy contains 200 mg of caffeine which
is about as much caffeine in a sixpack
of Coke does it right there on legally
the smallest font you could put it in
however looking at the caffeine amounts
of some other drinks currently on the
market in the US paints a slightly
different picture let's be clear 200 Mig
in this can is a lot of caffeine pound
for pound it contains more caffeine than
Monster Energy or Red Bull but other
American drinks such as bang energy or
Celsius heat contain 300 Mig per can
that's 50% more than Prime we don't have
these in the UK I've never heard of bang
or Celsius energy and they sound
terrifying one distinction that Senator
Schumer is highlighting is that Prime is
aimed at a kids Market despite the fact
that the can says not for children under
the age of 18 now if that is the case
Prime still isn't the biggest offender
gfuel a brand that appears to also
appeal to kids specifically in the
gaming space has several drinks with 300
milligram of caffeine they got flavors
like rainbow sherbet snow cone hype
sauce they contain more caffeine than a
prime as well as celebrity branded
flavors from PewDiePie and someone or
something called One Shot girl both have
300 mg of caffeine in the can where's
the outrage for
that a bottle of ice pop Prime hydration
in the US contains all of this in the UK
a bottle of ice pop Prime hydration
contains the following so in the UK our
Prime has slightly more calories but
less sodium if you grab yourself a prime
energy I have the lemon lime flavor it
contains all of this in the UK the same
drink albe it in a slightly smaller can
contains the following so it's almost
identical to Americas although we have a
little bit more sodium from exclusive
items to portion sizes we wanted to find
out all the differences between Chinese
takeout in the US and the UK this is
food
Wars here are all the menu items you'll
find any UK Chinese Takeaway that you
might not find in the US here is all of
the Chinese takeout we got at our local
spot that you might not be able to find
in the UK we'll start with the
appetizers in the UK it's pretty common
when you order a Chinese to order a few
starters and you kind of eat them
alongside your meal one thing to point
out almost all of these are beige and I
think that's going to be a bit of a
theme as we go throughout this episode a
lot of British Chinese food is just kind
of beige fried stuff and we love it
we'll start with an exception to the
beige rule with Crispy seaweed it's
actually got a misleading name because
this isn't seaweed it's shredded cabbage
which is then deep fried it's always
aggressively salty sometimes you get a
little bit of kind of like fish flakes
sprinkled on top I think this one is
basically just fried cabbage with some
salt powder on
it when we had a Chinese Takeaway at
home it would pretty much be the only
green thing on our plates and here's
what we got for our exclusive appetizers
starting with the steamed
dumplings that's so good I love a
dumpling another pretty iconic starter
is a chicken sat skewer they will take a
piece of chicken put it on a skewer
Grill it up in a kind of sat sauce which
is is mostly peanuts and they serve it
to you there we also have a bit of
additional saté sauce for dipping as
well these are great they're always like
a little bit dry I think that's why you
have to have the sauce on the side as
well next we have the scallion pancake
which literally looks like a cut up
little pancake I'm going to take a
taste yeah it's really tasty I want to
dip this in something though I'm like
getting the urge to dip when I think of
a British Chinese Takeaway this might be
one of the main dishes that comes to
mind these are sweet and sour chicken
balls so the sweetened sour bit actually
just refers to the sauce that it's
served with it's basically just a piece
of chicken which is then battered and
deep
fried mhm now these vary in quality a
lot from restaurant to restaurant if
chicken balls aren't your thing then we
also have the option of a prawn Bowl now
instead of a piece of chicken they take
an entire prawn batter it and deep fry
it kind of like a tempera prawn but I
think a lot heavier on the batter we've
been locked in a debate here as to if
there's any difference between prawn and
shrimp it seems like sometimes they're
used interchangeably but maybe they are
actually different species I don't know
if Nico you have any thoughts on the
differences between pora and shrimp
there is actually a difference between
shrimp and CRS it's not just linguistic
shrimp are more common in the US and
tend to be smaller with a more Savory
flavor when compared to prawns Charlie
is saying that when he's had it in the
past it's been like a sort of prawn
paste mashed up into a bowl whereas
these ones are just whole prawns inside
some batter so I feel like I've got a
better deal here this is a fried won
it's so cute it looks like a little
flower that is so good and crunchy next
up I did want to take a look at British
wantons I know you can get these in
America but I thought there might be
some differences so these ones are not
crispy these are steamed pretty tasty
not something that I would commonly
order moving on we have the crab ring
goons these are like kind of a meme now
for some reason I don't know why these
have like a spike in popularity just
like in general but this is what they
look like kind of similar to a won but
bigger let's crack this bad boy open oh
Gorge The Filling is just crab and cream
cheese I get it I think I get why it's
so popular this is a banger when you
talk about your beige food Mount
Rushmore this has got to be up there
this is cesame prawn toast you have four
beige Foods immortalized forever in
stone now if you order a full English
breakfast in the UK you're likely to
find some fried bread on there basically
what Chinese restaurants in the UK have
done is Elevate fried bread by putting a
layer of prawn paste in the middle and
then topping it with loads of sesame
seeds these are delicious I love these
moving on we have the spare ribs I have
to admit I've never had a spare rib it's
not something I've ever
ordered these have bones that's
literally a bone I thought I ordered the
boneless spare ribs but I guess I
ordered the spare ribs with the peeking
duck sauce and they look and smell
amazing so I am going to take a bite
anyway yeah that's literally so good
that is so good why don't I order ribs
that's so yummy now I was shocked when I
saw these as an exclusive in this
episode but our next one is prawn
crackers these are another thing that
you'll see on pretty much every UK
Chinese Takeaway order even if you don't
order them often they'll just throw you
in a bag for free they're just great for
like mopping up bits of sauce or
something you can also dip them in the
sweet and sour sauce and you kind of get
this
crackling I really almost hope that
we've made a mistake in this script and
that you can in fact find these on
Chinese takeout menus in the US because
they're great and you guys are missing
out the last two items we want like to
talk about were chips we have two
versions here that you'll find on pretty
much every British Chinese Takeaway menu
we have regular chips and we have salt
and pepper chips as I'm sure some of you
might know British people don't tend to
have the most adventurous pallets in the
world and there's usually a lot of
demand for chips same with Indian
restaurants and Chinese restaurants
basically they're just catering to the
demand of the British public also it's
very common to pair your chips with
curry sauce so curry sauce in this sense
it probably has some of the similar
flavorings that you would find in like a
katsu curry type sauce I would refer to
this type of curry sauce as like chip
shop curry sauce and that kind of
applies to whether it's Chinese
takeaways or fish and chip shops then we
also have the salt and pepper chips now
salt and pepper seasoning is quite
common at Chinese restaurants in the UK
that refers to a seasoning mix which is
comprised of salt white pepper and
Chinese five spice they kind of take
that base it around it they'll make
chips cook them most of the way and then
finish them usually in a walk with some
chili peppers some onion and some spring
onion these are delicious now I will
defend salt and pepper chips but they
were kind of at the center of that Tik
Tock controversy around British Chinese
food which honestly is kind of why we've
made this episode I also got an order of
fries obviously these are not an
exclusive just to us Chinese takeout
places but I just wanted to show what
they looked like here versus in the UK
very Bland I don't even think these have
salt on them which is kind of
interesting this is definitely one of
those Chinese takeout menu items that
feels very catered to a different kind
of palette I would say that I do not see
people ordering french fries pretty much
ever from a Chinese food place something
like this is probably for like kids who
are picky eaters which I definitely was
I was ordering white rice and chicken
wings from Chinese takeout as a child
because I didn't want to try anything
else but that's what this feels like
something to please the children I'm
calling Harry a child right now
something to please the child another
British Chinese takeout staple is a
crispy aromatic duck pancake now it sits
somewhere kind of between an appetizer
and a main course cuz I mean if you gave
me enough of this I would just eat that
as my main it can be kind of expensive
so I feel like some people just get a
little bit to share so it it's neatly
packaged for us but it comes in a few
different components obviously we have
the crispy aromatic duck itself these
little crispy bits of skin are amazing
we have the pancakes we have hoisten
sauce and then you have your vegetables
in this case we have some Julien
cucumber and spring onion I'll I'll do a
little demo assembly here I feel like
everyone's got different ways of
assembling so don't judge mine start
with a pancake get as much of that
crispy skin as possible couple bits of
Cuke some spions hoiston is is like kind
of a plum based sauce so it's nice and
sweet works really well with the Savory
have some fun with it you know beautiful
these are Sensational I've not actually
had one of these in a
while next let's talk about the
exclusive soup options we have this is
vegetable bean curd soup I should
mention that I never order soup when I
get Chinese takeout but I it's obviously
going to vary from person to person some
people like a little soup appetizer I'm
not one of those
people although I love soup in general
it mostly just smells like broccoli to
me it doesn't have a super strong flavor
I feel like the broth isn't as rich as I
wanted it to be but the tofu is really
tasty next we have the hot and sour I've
never had hot and sour soup before so I
am interested to try it this smells a
lot like sweet and sour sauce so I
assume that that's what's in here I'm
seeing vegetables what I think is tofu
it smells really good so let's take a
little
slurp the texture is not my favorite I
think it's like got the texture of a
sauce to me so like sipping it like a
soup doesn't feel right but it does
taste good and lastly we have the egg
drop soup which I feel like is a pretty
popular soup when you're ordering
Chinese takeout here the one we got here
is chicken and sweet corn which I think
is kind of like the archetypal Chinese
Takeaway soup here in the UK I won't
necessarily go out of my way to order
one of these although I do think they're
pretty tasty one thing to point out
though is the texture of these cuz if
you're not used to it it can really take
you by surprise there's something about
a chicken and sweet corn soup in
particular that's just so comforting we
actually do have a corn and chicken soup
here too I just don't think it's as
popular as something like a hot and sour
soup in the UK we have a lot of fried
rice dishes these probably could be
ordered as your main meal but I would
say in the UK they're more traditionally
ordered alongside a meat or vegetable
dish and kind of enjoyed together we
picked out a couple of options here is
the house special fried rice and then
also we have the Singapore fried rice I
just wanted to find out what makes this
the house special fried rice because
usually it will include a variation of
kind of things mixed in in with it
there's little pieces of chicken pork
and prawn in here as well as some spring
onions the Singapore fried rice seems to
actually have the same fillings CU I'm
seeing these little tiny shrimps in them
seeing bits of chicken and pork as well
but I think this is supposed to be a
slightly spicier fried rice so let me
give this one a quick
try not like overpoweringly hot but
definitely more of a chili kick to that
one moving on to our fried rice option
we only have one and this is the Young
Chow fried rice it's basic basically
made with a bunch of different protein
options looking down right now I just
see Spar ribs I see chicken I see shrimp
looks kind of good I've never thought of
eating multiple Meats at one time like
this I would argue and say that fried
rice in general is like a popular food
here I make it all the time like it's
such an easy dish to make at home and
it's definitely popular at Chinese
takeout places but for some reason we
only had one exclusive option at this
particular location I'm going to try to
get a bite with every single meat on it
oh oh there it
is it is a very odd taste when it's
three different Meats at once but it's
not bad it's actually pretty good now
chain has to be one of the most popular
dishes in the UK I think surveys have
actually placed it as the number one
dish it's pretty versatile so usually
again this would be an accompaniment to
maybe like a meat Dish as well or you
could kind of just eat this on its own
personally chicken chain is my favorite
and I think probably most Brit's
favorite too but you can also just get
plain vegetable or various other
toppings here we have the chicken Chowan
it's effectively just a stir fried
noodle dish Chowan definitely is a thing
here it just isn't a thing at this
particular restaurant I'm sorry I have
to repeat myself so much let's talk
noodles this is the pan fried noodle
this is the l Main and this is the
Singapore May fun opening this up I knew
exactly what it smelled like it smells
like Curry so there has to be some sort
of Curry element in it it smells really
good so I think I'm going to take a bite
I've never had this before and it also
looks like they use a smaller noodle
than in either of these two dishes it's
like those thin is it like vermicelli
noodles vermicelli noodles that's my
daughter's
name this dish also has multiple
proteins going on I'm seeing chicken and
I'm seeing shrimp I don't know if
there's anything else underneath but
that's what I see right now the flavor
is pretty good I don't know if I like
vermell noodles I think this is my first
time having them they're just such a
thin noodle I like something chewier
like the ones that come in the low man
once you get the rice and the noodle
portions the Chinese Takeaway menus in
the UK are usually categorized by
protein so you'll choose either chicken
pork beef or anything else and then you
kind of choose a sauce that goes with
that for example we can get sweet and
sour chicken but you can also get sweet
and sour pork and sweet and sour beef
from each protein category we're going
to show you a couple of either
interesting or unique food items let's
start with chicken here I have lemon
chicken this is another one of those
that's probably going to be found on
pretty much every Chinese Takeaway menu
in the UK the sauce is pretty good
though it's lemony a little bit sweet a
little bit tart then here we have the
kungo chicken you might also see this
referred to as kungpow chicken with that
a in the middle there but it's the same
dish it's basically not too dissimilar
to sweet and sour chicken that you might
find on the menu at a UK Chinese takeout
it's these dredged and fried pieces of
chicken in a sweet and spicy sauce
kungpow chicken I think traditionally
also would have some peanut in it in the
US it's exactly the same our menus are
categorized by the protein type but a
lot of the dishes are really different
so you don't always get the same sauce
for say a seafood Dish as you would a
chicken dish let's start with the chopi
which I have never had before but I'm
very interested you can get it with any
protein we got ours with chicken and
here's what that looks like the chicken
looks a little pale I feel like this is
a surprisingly Bland dish compared to a
lot of other chicken dishes I've had
from Chinese takeout it's definitely not
my favorite moving on to the sesame
chicken this was like a fan favorite I
was told I had to get this I'm not a
sesame chicken orderer but my friends
and co-workers
are yeah it's so good next we have
orange chicken which as the name
suggests has orange in the sauce and
this particular place uses like the
orange peel to like season the chicken
I've definitely had a lot of orange
chicken in my day particularly the
Frozen kind from Trader Joe's so it is
pretty popular
it's not a spicy sauce it's definitely
just like a sweet Tangy sauce but it's
very delicious and last but not least we
have General s chicken which is my
personal favorite thing to order from
Chinese takeout you'll see it on a lot
of Chinese restaurant menus here in the
US but it's not exactly authentic
Chinese food shocker General sa was a
real General from the Hunan Province who
supposedly enjoyed eating a dish similar
to General sa chicken although This
Modern American version would probably
be unrecognizable to him the dish was
actually created in the 1950s by a chef
named Pang Chang Quay when he immigrated
to New York in 1973 he altered his
recipe to cater to the American palette
which in this case means he made it
sweeter Pang Chang qu called it general
sa's chicken because he and general sa
are from the same town then we're on to
the beef options now firstly I have to
shout out what might be my favorite
British Chinese Takeaway dish which is
crispy shredded beef with chili one
thing I've got to say talking a lot
about textures and crispiness here what
you will often find from Chinese
takeaways in the UK the actually break a
little hole in the plastic container
this is probably the first thing that
I'm ordering when I'm ordering a Chinese
Takeaway what they do is they get these
little slivers of beef dredge them
usually in something like cornflour fry
them up and then toss them in this
lovely sweet and spicy chili sauce I
just love the variation you get like
some of them will be slightly chewier
some of them will be
crispier flavors are great next up we
have some Sichuan beef now I really
enjoyed hearing Taran talking about San
Flav with the peppercorn when we were
doing the US versus China series go
check that out but I think sesan food
tends to be pretty spicy and they also
used sesan peppercorns which give you
this kind of like numbing effect in your
mouth the beef here also isn't fried
it's more just like pieces of brazed
beef I'm kind of intrigued to uh give
this a try although I'm worried about my
spice
tolerance yeah it's pretty spicy it's
very tasty very flavorful and then
finally we got some beef in black bean
sauce I'd say this is a pretty common
one as well and this is one that you can
also get in different meat varieties so
you can get this with the chicken with
the pork anything else comes with loads
of peppers as well some chili in there
onions it's a nice like very rich sauce
that's really good that with some rice
beautiful pairing we'll often actually
get this one this is one of my favorites
I feel like I've said that about a lot
of things I think I just ordered too
much Chinese Takeaway there's a variety
of beef dishes that you can get at
Chinese food places here in America
today we got the Mushu beef so it's got
cabbage some mushrooms obviously the
beef let's take a taste the beef in that
is really really tender and delicious I
actually really like this Seafood is
also a pretty common option on UK
Chinese Takeaway menus a lot of the
options you will find have similar
sources to some of the beef or pork
options but there are also a few unique
ones as well firstly we have salt and
pepper squid you might remember the salt
and pepper chips from earlier it's
basically crispy squid cooked in that
same seasoning sometimes this might be
found under appetizers today they had it
in their main section so we're going
with that I love crispy squid the way
that they kind of like cut it with this
cross-hatch pattern particularly in
Chinese cuisine gives it a really nice
nice texture it's not that chewy it's
really flavorful not super fishy just to
illustrate that sometimes the sources
are the same in different parts of the
menu this is the pepper and black bean
sauce again but this time with Squid
then we have a couple of prawn options
as well here we have the king prawns in
oyster sauce and King prawns with cashew
nuts while we have the prawn here in its
uh unbolded form let me get one of those
out Nico how does that look is that a
prawn or a shrimp or neither that prawn
kind of looks shrimpy to me it certainly
does not look like like a king prawn
that's not the king of the prawns in the
US shrimp is definitely the most popular
seafood option when you get Chinese
takeout we have a couple of shrimp
options here the sesan shrimp and a
seafood Delight which has shrimp in it
and I'm guessing other delightful sea
creatures that's just shrimp is that
what is delightful or do they mean
Delight is like you get a bunch of
veggies with it let's just try the
sichan shrimp it smells as spicy as I
think it's going to be this is probably
the biggest shrimp I've seen
today I swear I've eaten with a fork
before oh no it's tail on it's spicy not
as spicy as I thought it was going to be
but I'm sure the more you eat it the
spicier it gets but that sauce is really
really good and the shrimp is awesome
even though it's got tails on it take
the tails off we also got a shrimp egg
roll Harry really wanted me to try this
and I'm glad he mentioned it because
I've never had a shrimp egg roll before
just pork that's what what I get every
time do you see that one little tiny
piece of
shrimp I feel like it tastes slightly
different than the pork not just because
the meat is different another item
you'll see in a lot of Chinese
restaurants in the US is egg fu young
it's an omelette made with vegetables a
protein and a stir fry sauce whoo baby
this is a big omelette it smells really
good it doesn't just smell like egg it
smells like a lot of good stuff it needs
a lot more salt actually I wonder if
you're supposed to like add sauce or
something on top I think we're actually
supposed to add this gravy to it so let
me add that and see if it helps with the
salt Factor this feels very UK core
right now me pouring this gravy all over
food
better still not great I don't know if I
like this yeah egg for young is
interesting but I'm not sure British
people would really be going in and kind
of ordering just an omelette from a
Chinese Takeaway I'm not sure how well
that would take off over here it's time
for sauce talk sauce talk if there was
ever a time to do sauce talk it's now so
in front of me here I have all the
sources that were on offer at the
restaurant we ordered from I'm going to
go through them now explain what they
are what they might be paired with and
give them a try we'll start with a
slightly Infamous one it's British curry
sauce the British went around the world
took spices from everybody and this is
somehow the only thing that we came up
with Brits love curry sauce or at least
this iteration of curry
sauce there's definitely like some heat
there not a lot it's quite a gentle
spice flavor there's something about the
texture that is just really satisfying
that really gloopy like corn starchy
texture goes excellently with chicken
balls you'll often see Brits drizzling
this onto chips chips and curry sauce is
a big thing in the UK or you'll just see
it drizzled across your entire succulent
Chinese meal I also Joe really loved
that when we did our fish and chip shop
Food Tours episode it's not just the
Brits who can enjoy it then we have
another iconic UK Chinese takeout sauce
which is sweet and sour depending on
where you get it from the color again
will vary it's a pretty well balanced
one the first thing that hits your
tongue is the sour then it pretty
quickly Mellows out and you get a nice
sweet aftertaste again I think this is
kind of intended to be paired with the
chicken balls or PRN balls or something
else like that but I do think a lot of
Brits will just kind of coat their
entire meal in it while we're on the
subject of these iconic sources I also
have to shout out the poyene cups I
think Americans might call that
styrofoam but these are really iconic
this is the standard delivery vessel for
your sources the restaurant that we
ordered from had two chili options
firstly we have sweet chili Brits love
sweet chili this is on the menu at a lot
of restaurants and then the next one we
have is chili oil I'd say this one isn't
super commonly found on like UK Chinese
takeout menus next up we have the black
bean sauce now this is the same sauce
that you might have seen in some of the
dishes earlier then we got two more
sources first up we have hoisen sauce
now this is most commonly paired with
the crispy duck that you'll find on UK
Chinese takeout menus it's a very thick
dark brown sauce again gloopy sauces we
love it I think the main ingredient in
Hoisin sauuce or one of the main
ingredients is plum so you get this real
sweetness from it which works very well
with the Savory duck meat and other
things on the menu and then finally we
have Barbe sauce now I was a little bit
confused when I saw this on the menu
because barbecue sauce in the kind of
Western sense so like a Texas barbecue
sauce for example does not look like
this and I think that's what I was
expecting but I think what's actually
been delivered is much more of a Chinese
style barbecue sauce what this one makes
me think of is more when you eat like a
Charo pork bun for example cuz while it
is barbecuey it's still got some
sweetness to it there's Chinese five
spice in here but if you're expecting
like Hines barbecue sauce that's not it
I think out of all of these ones the one
I will reach for the most will be the
sweet and sour sauce it's because almost
always order the chicken balls when I'm
making a Chinese takeout order in the UK
and one of these will come with it yeah
I think in the UK it's kind of just the
definitive Source closely followed by
Curry I think that's one of the biggest
differences between Chinese takeout in
the US and the UK our takeout comes with
the sauce already Incorporated for the
most part you do get a mix though of
tiny little sauce packets like this so
we've got soy sauce Duck Sauce which is
so good it's kind of just like a sweet
sauce we have mustard usually which I'm
not seeing here but you do get mustard
and hot sauce I'm pretty sure there are
more but that's just what we have right
now and then we have a couple little
cups of this looks like a paste I think
that this is a little tiny container of
oyster sauce and this is just a little
container of extra soy sauce probably
for dipping if you do not have a drawer
full of these sauces I don't know what
you're doing I feel like everybody has
that drawer in their house that's filled
with random sauce packets like
this now that we've covered every item
individually what I wanted to do was
show you my ideal plate of British
Chinese Takeaway food you might have
seen these on Tik Tok or elsewhere as
these kind of broke the internet a while
ago but I'm going to show you my version
I need some
Chowan the amount of carbs that might
end up on this plate could be alarming
to some cuz we're going to go noodles
also going to go rice you know we're
going to get the salt and pepper chips
involved then I want a healthy portion
of my crispy chili beef I'm going to
want some seaweed on here some of this
prawn toast definitely a couple of
spring rolls
and of course our prawn crackers as well
so genuinely speaking this is a pretty
normal plate of Chinese Takeaway food
for a British person but we're not done
there the final step of course is to add
our sauces yes that sauce is plural
because we're going to be adding both
the curry sauce and the sweet and sour
sauce to this and honestly I'm not
discriminating here this is going pretty
much on the entire meal and of course
our sweeten sour
sauce love it or hate it that is your
typical plate of British Chinese
Takeaway food I think I've done a pretty
good job there British people please
feel free to agree or disagree with me
in the comments below Nico I've got to
hear your thoughts about this would you
eat this let me stop you right there why
do you guys sauce the whole plate like
doesn't the whole plate just then taste
like that sauce you want everything to
taste exactly like that sauce bone up
the teeth now let's make up an American
plate of Chinese takeout with a bunch of
staple foods that I think are pretty
nationally beloved I would say let's
start with our sides our little
appetizers so we'd probably throw a
couple of wontons on there I'd also do
some type of roll I would usually do an
egg roll but all we've got left are
spring rolls next you'd have your rice I
prefer white rice I just think it's
really easy to pair with any sort of
entree okay I wouldn't normally eat the
full container rice but we're going to
keep it on the plate we got to get some
chicken you definitely need a side of
veg so we're going to do broccoli cuz I
feel like that's literally at every
single Chinese restaurant they have
broccoli on the side if you ignore the
huge mountain of white rice I think this
looks pretty appetizing the last thing I
would add to this plate is probably some
line so let's do that I didn't mention
these before but these little fried I
think they're fried noodle pieces they
come with soups so you can just throw
them in your soup have them with your
soup they're just good to snack on I
think this looks like a pretty
appetizing plate this is probably the
point where folks in the UK would douse
their plate in sauce I would do things a
little differently I really like dipping
egg rolls into the Duck Sauce which is
this one it's so good and some people
put sauce I think over their rice and
stuff so we have our white rice our wons
our fried noodles some spring rolls a
side of broccoli sesame chicken and the
low man which I think this kind of sums
up what a typical order from a Chinese
food place would look like here in
America if it doesn't look like what you
would order sorry babe I don't know what
to tell you this is just what I think I
can't even believe I didn't mention it
yet you have to get a can of Coke on the
side any soft drink really will do I
just think you need a can of soda with
your Chinese takeout it's just it's a
sensation like no other it's it goes
together in the UK when we order food to
be delivered we say we're ordering a
takeaway rather than ordering takeout
also in the UK we tend not to bother
adding the words food or takeaway to the
type of food we're eating for example if
we're ordering Chinese takeout most
Brits will just say that we're having a
Chinese same applies for maybe Indian
food when you have an Indian or even a
full English breakfast in the US we call
it takeout they obviously both mean the
same thing but that's just our preferred
way of saying it we also say Chinese
food or Chinese takeout rather than just
a Chinese we also wanted to look at how
each country packages its food in the UK
you might find your Chinese food in one
of these foil boxes with a paper lid the
other most common form of packaging is
one of these clear plastic tubs and then
finally for your appetizer options such
as some spring rolls which we've got
here they generally will just come in a
paper bag I've always seen those folded
card BL boxes in American TV shows and
they do look pretty cool I have to say
also the cute little takeout boxes are
something that I feel like we see a lot
maybe in media when someone orders
Chinese food but they're not super super
common mostly the food comes in these
kinds of containers which is like a
black Tupperware with a clear top these
are usually reserved for the rice maybe
the L but it's not reserved for like all
of the food options these boxes were
actually inspired by Japanese origami
Frederick weeks Wilcox was the first
person to introduce the paper pale box
in the 19th century to carry raw oysters
he created a patent for it and called it
a paper paale which it basically is it's
like a cute little
pale in the UK and the US portion sizes
and menu items will vary slightly
depending on the different restaurants
that you go to but we did want to
compare a couple of standard menu items
in the US and the UK to see who might be
getting bigger portions one iconic
appetizer from a Chinese Takeaway in the
UK is the spring roll the restaurant
that we ordered from serves these in a
portion size of six in the US spring
rolls are made a little bit differently
they're made with rice paper and they
have thinly sliced vegetables on the
inside side this particular Chinese
restaurant only gave us two but I have
ordered from some places that give you
more it just depends on where you order
from we do have egg rolls which are kind
of similar to the UK these come in only
one size as far as I know but depending
on what place you order from they could
be like a little bit bigger a little bit
smaller than this my local place they're
actually a little bit bigger than this
size in the UK our egg fried rice only
came in one size I don't want to weigh
this outside of the box so I'm just
going to wear in the Box this is a
mountain all of this rice just came out
of this tiny little container so this is
what our fried rice looks like at this
particular restaurant they only had one
size of this fried rice but I have seen
places do small and large sizes all
right let's weigh this mountain of
rice it's like just maxed out the scales
that's a lot of rice we do have chicken
included in that just letting you know
and we did weigh the plate beforehand so
that's not part of this weight the
restaurant that we ordered from had Chow
in two different sizes regular and large
although the large was only available
with certain varieties so this is a
chicken chow regular size and this is
the house special chain and a l CH we do
have Chow here in America but we didn't
have it at this particular restaurant we
do have pan fried noodles which I think
are similarish so we're going to weigh
these although I feel like it might once
again be slightly too heavy for the
scales moving on to sweet and sour
chicken that is like a tried and true
classic with takeout I think that I'm
supposed to sauce it myself which isn't
the norm for me in my experience getting
Chinese takeout everything is already
like Sauced you don't need to add
anything this time they came without
sauce so we're just going to add it
ourselves in the UK our sweet and sour
chicken came in one size in the UK
this's consists of little fried pieces
of chicken peppers onions and also
pineapple I'm getting word that I think
I was supposed to dip the individual
pieces into sauce and eat it like that
I've never ordered this I just know it's
a common takeout item year but I I
already poured the sauce all over it so
let's just wait and see how much it
is as we mentioned before each Chinese
restaurant is unique as to how they
prepare and cook their food so it's kind
of impossible to know exactly what's
going into each dish one ingredient that
we did want to highlight however as it's
commonly associated with Chinese food is
MSG or monosodium glutamate in 1907 a
Japanese chemist named kikuna ikada
discovered a substance called glutamate
also known as Umami he later broke that
substance down into MSG MSG is a
seasoning and food enhancer that gives a
rich Savory flavor MSG is actually very
commonly found in fast foods including
Chick-fil-A snack foods including
Doritos and naturally occurs in some
cheeses MSG has been recognized as safe
by the FDA several times and only
contains a third of the sodium content
of table salt so why is it got such a
bad rap in 1968 the New England Journal
of Medicine published a letter titled
Chinese restaurant syndrome in it a
doctor describes his experiences after
eating at Chinese restaurants citing
symptoms like numbness in the back of
the neck General weak weakness and
palpitations the blame was placed on MSG
and the Chinese restaurant syndrome myth
quickly spread the phrase even ended up
in the Mariam Webster dictionary despite
there being no evidence that MSG was
dangerous there was still a public Panic
around it Chinese restaurants in
particular were deemed unhealthy
thankfully the use of MSG is much more
normalized today although the xenophobic
misinformation from the 1960s does still
linger if you Google MSG some of the
suggested Search terms include things
like why are Americans afraid of MSG and
is MSG a neurotoxin short answer no it's
not
the first Chinese restaurants to appear
in the UK were called eating houses they
would serve Chinese Sailors who would
dock in British ports this goes as far
back as the 19th century when Hong Kong
was part of the British Empire notable
locations for this included Limehouse
which is part of the East End of London
and was actually where the original
Chinatown was the East End of London was
particularly hit by bombing raids in the
second world war which caused Chinatown
to relocate to Soho where it is today
the first recorded Cantonese restaurant
in London was a place called CA and it
was opened in 1908 it was opened by a
former ship's Chef a guy called chanun
it was chun's son who opened a
restaurant in baywater decades later
which might have been the kind of origin
of the Chinese Takeaway in London
apparently the food was so popular that
if customers couldn't get a table they
would simply ask for the Food To Go
chun's restaurant Maxim had a very
popular dish consisting of pork and a
sweet and sour sauce called Jiao while
the origins of the dish are specifically
Cantonese it just became known as
Chinese food to Britain the first known
Chinese restaurant in the US was called
Canton and opened in 1849 in San
Francisco the 18 50 saw the appeal of
the gold rush so to escape worst
conditions in China there was a flood of
Chinese immigrants in this time
restaurants began popping up to feed
Chinese workers who missed their Cuisine
from home modifying their favorite
dishes using ingredients that they could
find in the US in 1882 the Chinese
Exclusion Act forbade Chinese immigrants
from Coming to America an exception was
made for restaurant tours who could
apply for merchant visas which saw a
boom in Chinese restaurants opening up
in the 1910s any new restaurants that
opened had to be considered high grade
to be within the 1882 Act so the owners
lavishly decorated the restaurants and
by 1943 the Act was revoked during this
period dishes such as chopi and egg fu
young were popularized across the
country especially the spread of chapsui
houses chapsui was made from food scraps
its name basically means leftovers male
migrants who came over from China had
little to no kitchen skills and
ingredients were different from those
back home so they threw together what
they could find creating a dish that was
very easy to make chapsui was a popular
Chinese American dish up until the 1960s
after which general so chicken kind of
became the new popular thing also during
this time Chinese food began to be
preserved in cans for pickling and
freezing because the Great Depression
meant that people were looking for food
that was more affordable popularizing
the chopi houses was a turning point for
integrating Chinese cuisine into
American culture even if the dish was
eventually less popular Chinese food
increased in popularity in the UK during
and after World War II recipes for
Chinese Cakes as well as other simple
Chinese recipes were introduced to Brits
by the BBC and as some Brits returned
from being stationed in the Far East
they brought back with them a taste for
Chinese cuisine an influx of Cantonese
immigrants arriving from Hong Kong in
the 1950s brought with it a wave of
Chinese restaurants to the UK these
restaurants really blew up in popularity
the restaurants proved so popular in
fact that Billy butland introduced chopi
and chips to the restaurant menus at his
holiday camps one Trend that you also
saw was Chinese families taking over old
fish and chip restaurants this is why
you still see things like fish and chips
or battered sausage and chips on the
menu at some Chinese restaurants around
1960 The Mandarin opened in San
Francisco introducing Americans to
Chinese food Beyond chopi like hot and
sour soup and pot stickers Cecilia Chang
the owner of the restaurant wasn't sure
what food customers would want so she
added over 300 items to the menu
President Nixon's trip to China in 1972
began to normalize relations between the
countries and Americans were influenced
to try more Chinese food in 1989 the
National Restaurant Association
concluded that Chinese food was actually
the most frequently consumed Cuisine
across the country and over the next few
decades the number of Chinese
restaurants went up up by the thousands
in 2007 there were over 43,000 in the US
today there are over 23,000 Chinese
restaurants in the 1950s there were only
36 Chinese restaurants in the UK but the
next few decades saw that number rapidly
Ascend by the late 1990s that number had
risen to over 5,000 today there are a
little over 7,000 Chinese restaurants up
and down the UK according to a survey
Chinese food is the second most popular
cuisine in the US right behind Pizza as
of June 2023 a 2001 poll said that
Chinese food was British people's
favorite foreign Cuisine from exclusive
items to portion sizes we wanted to find
out all the differences between Cadbury
products in the US and the UK this is
food
wars in the UK classic dairy milk
chocolate comes in a bunch of sizes the
smallest one isn't sold individually but
it's one of these selection box
bite-sized pieces then we move up to one
of these little bars these are sold
mostly as a snack for children and they
weigh 18 G each then we have a
multi-pack bar which weighs 33.5 G then
we have what I would say is the standard
bar which is 45 G if you're feeling
hungry you can have a Duo bar as you can
see by the crease in the middle it's
kind of separated into two smaller bars
and in total it weighs 54.4 G in terms
of standard dairy milk you may also be
able to find a 95 G bar we actually
found a 90 G bar of caram milk the
portion size varies slightly depending
on what type of chocolate you're getting
moving more into towards the larger
sizes we have a 110 G bar of dairy milk
up from that we have a 180 g bar our
second biggest size is this 360 G bar
and finally our biggest size is this
one that's 850 g of dairy milk in the US
our dairy milk bars come in one size the
3.5 oce or 99.2 G bar now this bar right
next to it the Caramelo is actually 4 oz
or 13.4 G right here in the middle
there's a fruit nut size that's 5.4 Oz
or 53 G I couldn't get it in
time but our I guess biggest size or
other size is this a bag of Miniatures
where it is an 8 o or 22 G bag but it's
always little guys in there our Cadbury
bar the 99.2 G bar comes in 18 squares
per bar if you divide it up it's 6 G per
square for comparison we'll take a look
at our 110 G bar of dairy milk in the UK
one of the These Bars has 24 individual
squares we're going to find out how much
one of those weighs so according to our
slightly inaccurate analog scales one
square weighs around 6 Gams although if
we divide the 110 figure by 24 we end up
with around 4.5 so somewhere between
there so there's no difference good on
you
Cadbury here are all the cury products
from the UK that you won't find in the
US here are all the Cadbury products in
the US you won't find in the UK this is
going to be an easy one for me now I
want to remind the audience that this is
for Cadbury products produced in our
respective countries yes all that stuff
is available on Amazon we know now
obviously we have a ton of exclusive
products here in the UK so we're going
to break them down into categories we'll
start with standard dairy milk bars but
with different flavorings we're going to
start off with a bang here with what's
possibly my favorite just standard Dairy
Milk Bar which is cabri whole nut it's
basically fruit and nut but with none of
that gross fruit in there it's just the
nuts fruit and
nut whole nut now depending on what time
of year you're looking for your cab in
the Market you might be able to find
Orange Dairy Milk but because we're in
the buildup to the festive season we got
winter orange crisp instead chocolate
and orange is kind of a beloved flavor
combination here in the UK I think a lot
of people will think of Terry's
chocolate oranges but cabri are getting
in on the ACT next up we have cab dairy
milk Oreo you might see a few of these
as we go through they seem to have some
kind of partnership going on with Oreo
because there's actually quite a few
dairy milk X Oreo products I'll open
this one up because it's actually quite
cool what they've done to be fair from
the outside it looks just like a
standard piece of dairy milk but if you
see they've actually filled it with Oreo
cream but they also put little pieces of
the biscuit in so you get these like
crunchy bits as well if the cabri Dera
milk Oreo somehow isn't sweet enough for
you you can also get a white chocolate
Oreo bar we're sticking with the
classics here and we're moving on to
dairy milk caramel now I know I said
that this might have been too sweet for
me but I actually do really like the
caramel bars so what you get is Dam milk
chocolate but then you have this quite
liquidy
caramel on the
inside the caramel it is sweet but it's
not like it's not like you're just
tasting sugar you know there is
something else going on there we did see
that in the US you guys have Caramelo is
that kind of the same thing Joe what do
you think hi Harry and yes we don't have
the dairy milk caramel we have the dairy
milk Caramelo I remember Caramelo for a
while was a US brand I remember the
commercials it went like
Caramelo so so that's yours let's take a
look at ours here's ours it's already
like kind of coming out there it's
caramel heavy rich I guess yeah came I
got a straight answer if Cadre just
bought Caramelo in the US and repackaged
it or what but it looks like it's
probably relatively the same sticking
with the caramel theme we now have the
new salted caramel bar I feel like I
don't know if this is the case in the US
but there's been a real salted caramel
Takeover in the past couple of years to
the point where it's very hard to find
unsalted caramel now and and I suppose
Cadbury had to get on the
trend I really don't think I taste much
if any difference at all between that
and the regular caramel since I have
nothing else to do for this episode I'm
going to go ahead and try some of you
this UK cadberry I'm hearing so much
about starting with the OG cadberry
Dairy Milk
Bar yeah this is a much smoother nicer
richer REM your chocolate I do really
love this it's fantastic you brag a lot
about your chocolate UK but another
thing you should be bragging about is
your caramel it's also really good and
way better than what we have in America
saw the caramelos from earlier I just
not not the not the biggest fan of those
anymore I like that when I was a kid but
caramel in America is just too but yours
oh
yeah I mean pulls apart nicer now this
one got cheers of approval from the crew
when I mentioned it this is the Capri
dairy milk dime bar now for those who
don't know dime is a chocolate bar in
its own right and it's like a layer of
chocolate on the outside with quite a
hard layer of kind of tofe caramel on
the inside now dime bars themselves I
think have maybe fallen out of favor a
little bit in the UK they were very
popular with kind of like my granddad's
generation and I think people don't
really buy them on their own anymore
however I do say they are delicious you
can also still buy them in places like
Ikea I think they're popular kind of on
Continental Europe next up we have
another new bar it's the cadri white
confetti bar I've never seen this this
before before I went to do the shopping
for this episode but it's white
chocolate and it contains oat biscuit
pieces as well as milk chocolate beans
but you do see quite a few of these
biscuit
pieces yeah I get a lot of the
biscuit not much of the chocolate pieces
you may also be able to find a mint
dairy milk a crunchy pieces dairy milk
and also dairy milk with 30% less sugar
but I wasn't able to trap them down
today then we have a couple of dairy
milk bars with either slightly different
composition or flavors firstly we have
dairy milk marvelous Creations this one
has jelly popping candy inside don't
quote me on this but I feel like back in
the early 2000s in the UK we had a Wonka
series of chocolate bars which were
inspired by Willie Wonka now I think
that was actually a nesle product but
they had interesting flavors they did
things like putting jelly beans and
popping candy into their chocolate bars
they've disappeared don't know what
happened to them but I feel like this is
Cav's attempt to like get in on that
bring that back a little bit probably
pretty well timed because uh you know
the Wonka movies out soon it's going to
really date this video but we love
Shalom these are pretty good I do think
it's like an interesting textural
experience when you eat one of these cuz
it's the kind of chewiness of the Jelly
Bean mixed in with the melty milk
chocolate not my favorite but hey if you
want something a little bit different
than this is for you then we're on to
the big taste bars this is the dairy
milk big taste Oreo crunch I did mention
that there was a theme of dairy milk and
Oreo crossover products and this is the
next one in that line so with the big
taste bars They are thicker than a
standard chocolate bar would be and
because of that they have like layers
going on basically double the height so
here is the standard dairy milk Oreo and
here is the big taste Oreo as you can
see you get much more distinct layers on
this
one I'm going to be honest I think I
just prefer the standard one one iconic
cab product is the Fredo a Fredo is a
small individually wrapped chocolate bar
that's in the shape of a frog now you
can get two versions of this you can
either get a standard one which is just
milk chocolate or you can get a caramel
Fredo much like a dairy milk caramel bar
it's a shell of milk chocolate with that
kind of liquidy caramel on the inside I
love fros I feel like a lot of Brits
have a nostalgic attachment to them I
can't tell if they've shrunk over the
years or if I've just got bigger or
possibly both but I do feel like back in
the day when you're a little kid these
are a nice little like snack siiz treat
whereas nowadays this is like a mouthful
this is kind of tiny they're also worth
pointing out because in the UK they've
become an unlikely economic yard stick
when I was a kid they cost just 10 P but
the price has risen drastically over the
past few years at one point in 2017 the
price Rose as high as 30p for one of
these where I think it's now dropped
back down to 25 after probably a lot of
public outry because of the fluctuating
price they've kind of become a measure
of inflation and cost of living here in
the UK people's paychecks do not buy
them as many fros as they used to and
that is a sad thing that's funny Harry
and the US carbury tried what I think
are similar Shenanigans by decreasing
the size of the products back in 2007 us
comedian and actor BJ Novak outed
Cadbury on the Conan O'Brien show for
suddenly making Cadbury Eggs smaller in
the UK we also have a couple of
plant-based chocolate options they're
made with almonds instead of dairy in
order to try and replicate a milk
chocolate feel and they come in two
forms either as a classic bar or as a
salted
caramel it's actually not that bad
they've done really well I think to
replicate the texture of milk chocolate
cuz as it kind of claims on the
packaging smooth I think is the word it
really is quite a smooth experience it
does kind of melt in your mouth almost
like a milk chocolate bwood I think
what's letting it down really for me is
still the taste of it rather than than
the texture it tastes almost more like a
sort of uh cooking chocolate or like you
know when you get those really cheap
chocolate chips and feels like there
isn't enough cocoa or like creaminess to
them we have these four
exclusive bars here in the US we got uh
Rock the road which is milk chocolate
with roasted almonds
marshmallows and
fudge no I don't like that we have a
royal dark dark chocolate I'm sure you
have several dark chocolates ours is
royal not a big dark chocolate
guy not as bitter as I expect from dark
chocolate so not bad but I don't know
again just okay roasted
almond generous with the almonds right
it's a pretty good almond almond haul
last of our exclusive flavors are black
forest cake which is dark chocolate with
cherry flavored fudge and cookie pieces
oh man okay so apparently in the UK you
would call us a black forest gate which
is funny cuz you didn't use the French
words for black or Forest well I'm the
black forest in oh yeah that's right and
the black forest in Germany EU you guys
don't know what's going on uh going to
be honest with you chocolate and Cherry
not my favorite
combo oh God this is terrible this is
the worst one oh I hate this next up
we're on to buttons now cat buttons are
just pieces of dairy milk chocolate
shaped into little buttons or little
discs buttons come in a range of sizes
and flavors so the original ones are
actually tiny I feel like they've kind
of fallen out of favor or maybe you're
just kind of only given to kids but this
is what honestly the classic button
looks like and it's these really tiny
little chocolate discs it's literally
just plain dairy milk chocolate the ones
that I would more commonly go for in my
adult life are the ones which are served
in these big sharing bags and they're
more like this size you say that's like
that's more than double the size I would
say and then if that button size is
still not big enough for you then we
have mega buttons so we have classic
Giant and mega just one more note on the
size of the buttons we've observed that
the classic ones on the packet are just
called buttons but what I think used to
be called the giant ones are also now
just called
buttons which you can see because they
are still called giant buttons in the
orange flavored version you can you can
also get buttons in a range of flavors
so here we have some mint chocolate
buttons some orange chocolate buttons
these ones are called caramel nibbles
but I always thought they were just
caramel buttons because again they're
kind of the disc shape but with a little
pocket of caramel in the middle and you
can also get dark milk buttons now these
are a cabri invention which is somewhere
between dark chocolate and milk
chocolate as well as Cara milk buttons
and if you want just actual dark
chocolate Cab's calls that bourneville
and they have giant bourneville dark
chocolate buttons another cabri product
in the UK are cabri fingers now these
are a classic I feel like these are a
staple in a lot of British households
basically what you get is a layer of
biscuit along the bottom which is then
kind of just completely dunked in cabry
milk
chocolate can't figure out exactly what
the biscuit is I think it's kind of like
shortbread you can also get cab fingers
in a range of sizes and flavors for
example you can get these little
bite-sized pouches we have the Salted
Caramel fingers here but you can also
find white chocolate fingers orange
chocolate fingers mint chocolate fingers
and dark one thing which is just
launched in the UK at the time of
filming is Cadre Delights these are a
new range of products which I believe
are nugar covered in chocolate these
come in the flavors of hazelnut and
caramel orange and caramel and salted
caramel another exclusive we have in the
US are the mini chocolate eggs Harvest
eggs but it's around the holidays right
now so we have instead mini
snowballs I feel like they're the same
these are the same come
on yeah just milk chocolate with a uh
crisp sugary shell as they say in here
good for snacking I think um I think
these taste the best out of everything
here to be
honest also have the cream eggs couldn't
find them anywhere I thought they used
to be everywhere now they're gone I
don't know what happened to them but you
know what they look like we have
tragically we're filming this in
November so we can't get our hands on
our seasonal egg exclusives cab is
obviously known for cream eggs but also
has Mini Eggs which I believe are
excellent in the UK we can obviously get
the classic Cream Egg but we can also
get white cream eggs and caramel eggs we
can also get classic Mini Eggs as well
as a Mini Eggs bar however I will point
out that because it's in the runup to
Christmas we are able to get Heroes
right now which is a cab selection box
typically eaten around the holidays as
part of a hero's box you can get a
little bite-sized Twisted Cream Egg Bar
I get that like you know you want to
create that artificial demand but I feel
like people are going to eat cream eggs
year round regardless of availability so
I feel like you should just give the
people what they want have cream eggs
year round same for Mini Eggs please I
need those much more than cream eggs now
we're on to some exclusive chocolate
bars which you'll find in the UK but not
the US going to go through them in like
a roughly alphabetical order here
starting with the Boost bar now I
believe when these were first introduced
they were almost advertised as like an
energy bar in chocolate form because I
think they had like mortifying levels of
sugar and glucose in them whereas now I
think they've actually dialed back on
that and it's kind of just like a
chocolate bar with some biscuit and
caramel in the middle at the Boost bar
give me the Boost M everyone the UK's
watching me like this dummy's never had
this before no I haven't or if I had I
don't remember it now you might remember
from the buttons but when you see dark
chocolate and cadb it's going to be
marketed as bourneville comes in this
iconic red packaging as well compared to
the usual Purple colors used by C's fun
fact bourneville is actually a real town
which you can visit in the UK it was
created basically by Cadbury to house
all of their workers and apparently is
quite a nice place to live I'm not sure
why they've ended up using that name for
their dark chocolate range but here it
is you can get it in a few different
flavors here for example I have the old
Jamaica Flavor which is a dark chocolate
with rum and raisin we also have the
bourneville mint crisp bar you can also
just get it in a standard plain dark
chocolate one as well as an orange bar
as well next up we have caram milk so as
the name suggests this is kind of like a
caramelly milk chocolate hybrid which
cab has released over the past couple of
years what you end up with is this like
slightly weird yellowy golden
color kind of weird because it's got the
texture of like a milk chocolate but the
flavor is much closer to like a buttery
fudge you can also get caram milk in the
form of a a caram milk crispy bar which
is caram milk chocolate with little
crisp rice pieces speaking of crunch
next up we have a crunchy bar these are
pretty iconic basically what you get is
a honeycomb which is then dipped in milk
chocolate to produce a crunchy bar when
I say honeycomb obviously there's no
actual beehive in here what you do is
you mix melted sugar and I believe
baking soda and it kind of like erates
and puffs up and then solidifies to
leave you with what we know as kind of I
guess like confectionist honeycomb again
slightly controversial take I don't like
crunchy I don't like the texture of the
honeycomb on my teeth it feels really
weird and I don't enjoy it but I know
it's a very popular bar so you do you
that's fine next up is another possible
favorite of mine it's a curly whirly now
I love these because it sounds like an
American has kind of like improvise the
name for a British chocolate bar they're
a little bit hard to describe It's a
combination of chocolate and
toffee but it's in this very distinctive
unique shape I'm not really sure what
the logic is behind the shape but
I'm not sure if the same distinction
exists in America but here in the UK If
we say something has toffee in it that
implies that it's going to be very chewy
kind of similar to caramel in terms of
The Taste but a lot more
chewy curly whes let's go I have had
these before and I do really like them
oh
yeah yeah next up we have some more dark
milk products again this sits somewhere
between Queen darken milk chocolate on
the kind of cocoa content scale this one
is flavored with some little salted
caramel pieces more of the Salted
Caramel again with the Salted Caramel we
get it it's fine you might also be able
to find the same bar but flavored with
some hazelnut prene pieces next up is
another classic it's a double decker bar
our buses aren't the only things that
are double decker here in the UK we also
have these chocolate bars there's like
quite a lot going on in a double decker
bar I do love them I'm going to be
honest but so what you get is obviously
the dairy milk chocolate coating on the
outside
then on the inside you see you have this
big layer of nouar and on the other side
you have lots of these little crispy I
think kind of like crispy rice pieces
moving on from that we have a flake so I
don't really understand how flakes are
made but they are quite impressive
basically I think what they do is they
get like a kind of like waterfall of
chocolate and the way that it kind of
like hits the refrigerated surface it
kind of like folds in on itself and you
get this really like layered flaky
texture flakes are pretty iconic the
main use of flakes arguably in the UK is
in ice cream cones what you will usually
get is a whipped ice cream cone Mr
whippy and then a just stick of flake in
there as well flakes have also
apparently been the center of some uh
controversy this year because due to the
weird structure of them they don't melt
now unlike most of the chocolate that
I've been trying today I've kind of Come
Away with like little bits of melted
chocolate on my hand but basically due
to how thin the layers of the chocolate
are when it melts the solids and the
fats don't really separate like they
should do and therefore it just can't
melt you can put one of these in like a
ban Marie and it will just not melt you
can microwave one and it will just burn
before it starts to melt the fun facts
don't stop there we're rolling straight
in to the fries chocolate cream woo now
obviously these do not have the same
packaging or branding as the rest of
them but they are indeed manufactured by
cadb so these are bars of dark chocolate
with a fondant cream Center they're
worthy of special mention because these
are some of the first ever mass-produced
chocolate bars they take their name from
the fry family who were a Quaker family
from Bristol in the UK now the fries
were actually the first people to figure
out how to make mass-produced chocolate
bars we're going all the way back to the
1840s here in the UK but around that
time people only really drank chocolate
it was quite rare to get like you know a
piece of chocolate or a chocolate bar
the fries were the first ones who
figured out how to press cacao beans to
separate the fats from the solids now
they were doing this just to try and
make a drinking powder that was kind of
easier to dissolve but inadvertently
figured out how to separate all the
materials and then reincorporate them in
order to make a shelf stable chocolate
barath that's a taste of History right
there this is the packaging it's a fries
chocolate cream the packaging of this
one is suspicious it's like lowest
effort of packaging it's just this white
text no drop shadow a little bit of the
uh the bar right
there no I do not like this now while
they're not technically products
themselves rather an amalgamation of
products we have some selection boxes
here in the UK which are worth point out
now these will start to pop up in stores
around Christmas time which is when
they're usually eaten now these are
what's known as a selection box so
basically you have small individual
versions of quite a few of their
different chocolate bars which you can
then share with the family so the box of
Heroes will contain aa's fudge whisper
dairy milk crunchy bits twirl dairy milk
caramel double deer and the Cream Egg
Twisted we also have roses and these
aren't really based on existing Brands
these are more just like classic
chocolate box selections I suppose so we
have things like the orange cream the
strawberry dream we do actually have
some mini daring milk bars in here now
as well as a few other ones I feel like
in my power rankings of all the
chocolate selection boxes I don't know
if the cabry ones win for me I do think
celebrations might win for me which is
like the Mars brand equivalent of these
ones I'm thinking it's probably
celebrations Heroes roses on quality
Street of course the classics man
British Christmas what a wonderful time
while we're talking about selection
boxes I should also mention the
milkay now these are are a classic these
have been going back years and years and
years I feel like it's less of a thing
now but these were very very popular to
gift to people whether you know
someone's had you around for a dinner
party or it's a birthday give someone a
milk tray back in like the kind of 60s
or 70s it was just the dumb thing to do
back to the chocolate bars this is a
picnic bar I actually don't know if I've
ever had a picnic bar before mostly
because they contain raisins it's a milk
chocolate bar but then inside it's kind
of just like a mixture of everything you
get raisins you get peanuts there's
crispy cereal in there I think there's
caramel as well next up is the Cadbury
timeout wafer I'd say this is more of a
biscuit bar than a chocolate bar but you
have layers of biscuit and chocolate
which are then obviously coated in more
cury dairy milk chocolate then we're on
to a twirl these are kind of similar to
the flake in terms of the texture it's
kind of like flaked texture inside but
the actual individual bars are coated
with chocolate twirl what is a
twirl no I like this it's just okay I
don't like I don't like the um the Airy
texture of it man these are a classic I
feel like these have almost gone extinct
this is a Chomp bar it's kind of the
same as a curly whirly in that it's
basically a layer of toffee covered in
milk chocolate but instead of that like
weird pattering with the gaps this is
just a solid bar I feel like these have
always been served in this kind of small
size bar as more of a snack maybe aimed
towards kids but I love a Chomp he's are
brilliant sh it's a whisper bar I don't
fully understand whisper bars I like
them don't get me wrong but it just kind
of like feels like you're getting less
chocolate for your money than you are
with some other bars because basically
they've taken a milk chocolate bar but
they've figured out how to air rate it
and kind of like put little air bubbles
in what they've really gone for is a
texture where when you bite into it it
almost like melts on your tongue we also
have a whisper gold bar whisper gold is
the same air rated texture but it has a
layer of caramel running along the top
next up we have a star bar now the way I
see it this is just like a better picnic
bar so a star bar is basically just milk
chocolate on the outside caramel and
peanuts next up we have the fudge bar
it's a layer of fudge with some cabry
chocolate on the outside they're still
in the heroes box which I like but I
feel like not that many people like them
anymore and then finally for the time
being aa's so the cabir is very
different to the pastry eair it's
basically a bowl of tofe with chocolate
on the inside I always like these Al
there's always something really
satisfying about the texture of toffee
to me I had braces as a little kid and I
really missed tofe when I had
braces so I never take tofe for granted
it again now Cadbury in the US is a
brand that's manufactured by Hershey so
there's no sub Brands under Cadbury in
the United States however Hershey does
own about 29 Brands here are a few that
are exclusives to the US in no
particular order first one Milk Duds
been to movie theater in the US
recognize that sound some jerk sitting
two rows behind doesn't understand he's
making noise you got Milk Duds Milk Duds
are like Curly whirlies in button form
yeah that's actually pretty good what I
just did there it is just caramel
covered in chocolate but it is in button
form and not like drizzle form
these guaranteed stuck to your teeth
guaranteed you're digging these out of
your teeth a heath bar is hang on
English toffee in robed in Rich chocy
coating they they wrote that like they
thought an American would read that and
be like this is from England Mounds is
chocolate and coconut there it is it's a
mound looks a little bit like a rabbit
turd it's just a chunk
of coconut covered in dark chocolate now
if you're looking at this you're being
like it needs something else Joe yes it
does how about almonds Almond Joy the
exact same thing as a Mounds
but if said rabbit ate a bunch of
Almonds whole coconut and chocolate
coconut almonds and chocolate some of
the bars are also available in the form
of these bite-sized pieces these come in
bags notably we have some crunchy rocks
we have bits of whisper we have have
curly whirly Squires and the least fun
name 12 bites these are more designed to
be shared than obviously a classic
chocolate bar would be I think the idea
is maybe you get a bag of these take it
into the cinema or something watch a
film good a little snack next up we have
brunch bars these are ca's take on
cereal bars we've got these brunch bars
in three different flavors we have a
raisin one a milk choc chip one and a
dark choc chip one I do actually quite
like these these were like a occasional
packed lunch inclusion when I was
growing up basically it's it's a cereal
bar made mostly with
oats but then you get this base layer of
chocolate as well as in this case some
choc chips as
well yeah they've got like a nice chewy
texture and then finally it's time for
what we'll call the best of the rest
these are the kind of miscellaneous
cabry products which don't really fit
into any of the other categories but are
still worth talking about firstly we
have animal biscuits these were again
like a classic pack lunch staple when I
was younger you get a little biscuit
which on one side is kind of like
decorated in the shape of an animal and
on the other side is just dipped in
dairy milk chocolate got to give a shout
out to mini rolls these are another like
maybe Grandma biscuit tin staple these
are actually like a cake basically
rather than a biscuit or a chocolate bar
it's a roll of chocolate sponge cake
which is then like I say rolled up with
a little like layer of cream in the
middle and then the whole thing is
dipped in milk chocolate as
well and then while we're talking about
cadb cakes we also have cadb cake bar
kind of similar to mini rolls in that
you have the chocolate sponge it's all
coated in chocolate as well but you have
that caramel layer along the top then we
on to a couple of fridge desserts these
are Cadbury's milk chocolate sticky puds
so these are great I've had like these
or an iteration of these many times in
the past basically they come in these
little plastic pots which are
microwavable and the typical way to eat
these is that you maybe piss the film on
this put the whole thing in the
microwave for 30 seconds a minute or so
take it out flip it onto a plate and it
comes out cooking it kind of like steams
the sponge when it's in there and then
there's like a chocolate sauce as you
can see on the packaging which is kind
of collected at this end and then when
you flip it ends up kind of like
drizzling down the side of the puds and
it's very nice like a fun kind of like
fancy feeling dessert that you can just
have at home in 30 seconds PUD of course
is short for pudding which is what we
call dessert and then we also have these
dairy milk pots of Joy these are
apparently a smooth and creamy dessert
made with melted Cadbury milk chocolate
I've not had one of these before I think
they're like a yogurt basically like a
chocolate yogurt pot I'm not sure what
to make of this next one because it
feels a little bit like America is
infiltrating our CPR products but this
is cabri dairy milk fruer and nuttier
orange trail mix these I believe are new
I don't think Cab's been doing trail mix
for a very long time I also don't think
trail mix is very popular in the UK in
general like it's just not that common
so in a bag of this apparently you get
sweetened cocoa dairy milk orange
buttons raisins and sultanas roasted
almonds and hazelnuts speaking of things
meant to sound English it's a York
Peppermint Patty all the way from the
city of York it is this and is just
instead of coconut it
is peppermint Mr good
bar chocolate and peanuts this bar the
packaging you can tell this is an old
school bar this bar is so old that his
main selling point was like we assure
you there's peanuts in this B not l L to
you all right yes you won't believe how
packed with peanuts this bar is is this
true to the to
the the get the good bar guarantee in
the back possibly more wow they they
overd delivered on the promise of
peanuts Fifth Avenue by I don't know
what this
is whatam I call it let's go chocolate
peanut flavor crisps and
caramel definitely very peanut buttery
it's okay we have two options when it
comes to beverages for cadb in the UK
here we have original Cadbury hot
chocolate and then we also have
highlights milk chalk drink I'm not
massively sure what the difference is
but I think just judging from kind of a
look on the packaging highlights might
be designed as kind of like a diet
option just because it's described as an
instant low calorie milk chocolate
flavor hot drink staying in the cupboard
section of the Cab's aisle now we're on
to the chocolate spread this is
effectively kind of like a Nutella but
it doesn't have hazelnuts in it so this
is just like a pure chocolate spread now
we're moving on to the bakery section of
your Supermarket I got most of these
from an Asda in London so I do think the
availability will vary slightly
depending on where you are and which
Supermarket you're visiting but I will
say that most supermarkets will have a
bakery section and you'll probably see
some cab branding in there somewhere
here's what I was able to find we have
three of these bagged goods from the
bakery at Asda range firstly we have
some oaty bakes which are oat flapjacks
containing milk chocolate next up we
have some cabri daa milk shorty squares
shorty like a
melody in my Square shorty squares are a
short cake packed with again some dairy
milk chocolate chunks then we have some
Capri dairy milk chocolate cookies we're
staying in the bakery aisle now we're on
to dairy milk caramel Donuts now I'm
kind of intrigued by these I love
donuts it's just very dry and then we
have a few more baked good Goods namely
the dairy milk caramel mini cookies
dairy milk cornflake cluster bites and
some dairy milk brownie bites then we're
going to round things off with a few
seasonal items as I mentioned
unfortunately we weren't able to get the
Easter exclusives which are pretty
iconic namely the Cream Egg and the mini
egg but because we're kind of in the
Christmas Halloween period I was able to
get some of those exclusives instead
we'll start with the Halloween ones
which has just come and gone here in the
UK but we were able to find some mini
bonfire logs which are fun I think these
are like a mini roll but instead of the
classic kind of chocolate sponge they've
used a honey honeycomb sponge instead
and then another spooky seasonal
exclusive are the pumpkin patch cakes
these are chocolate cakes with an orange
colored cream filling then we have some
Cadbury Christmas puds these are dairy
milk chocolate bowls with a hazelnut
truffle Center hazelnut pieces and rice
crisps again it's that combination of
like chocolate and nuts just can't go
wrong for me and of course we can't talk
about seasonal exclusives without
talking about Advent calendars we love
our Advent calendars over here cadb of
course has to get involved and they have
a very simple but very effective
chocolate Adent
calendar this 110 G bar of cabri dairy
milk cost £35 at Tesco breaking that
down you're paying 1.22 P per gram of
chocolate in the US our bar is 99 G and
it cost
$2.79 which is 2.8 per gram so per gram
it's a 91% increase in the US ooh
getting gouged
[Music]
baby here's everything in a bar of dairy
milk chocolate in the UK milk sugar
cocoa butter cocoa Mass vegetable fats
palm and Shea emulsifiers e442 ammonium
phosphatides e476 polyglycerol poly
rolate and flavorings here's everything
in a US dairy milk chocolate far we got
sugar milk chocolate cocoa butter
lactose leathan PG PR natural flavor
artificial flavor UK chocolate is often
considered as Superior by some including
myself to us chocolate and there are a
few reasons for that firstly the UK
rules for its chocolate production from
the cocoa and chocolate products
regulations of 2003 set minimums for
milk chocolate at 25% total fat cocoa
butter and milk fat 5% milk fat 20% dry
cocoa solids 2.5% dry non-fat cocoa
solids and 20% dry milk solids in the US
our FDA rules for our milk chocolate
differ quite a bit 10% chocolate laor
12% milk salads which can be either
powder or condensed milk at least
3.39% fat and no more than 55% sugar
secondly those of us on this side of the
Atlantic can feel that American
chocolate has a sour almost vomity taste
to it that's all very well and good for
American brand Ed chocolate bars but why
doesn't us cury taste like it does over
here in the UK it starts with the
Hershey Company back in the early 1900s
the company introduced cost cutting
measures including a process to make its
milk last longer in production for this
they used a secret method called liosis
liosis
lipolysis the details of Hershey's
chocolate making process are a company
secret but part of the process involves
butc acid butc acid extends the shelf
life of milk but it does partially sour
it it's also found in Parmesan cheese
fermented foods like sauerkraut and of
course vomit vers became a powerful
Chocolate Company in the US so much so
they successfully forced a ban on an
import of Cadbury's chocolate into the
US in 1988 Hershey's acquired the US
Cadre license and has been producing it
in the US with their own Americanized
formula putting them in similar looking
Cadre packages ever since remember the
price section from earlier well it turns
out that not only are Americans paying B
basically double the price for their
chocolate as we are but they're also
getting a worse quality product that's
kind of
sad 100 G of dairy milk chocolate in the
UK contains the following 534 calories
30 G of fat of which 18 G are saturated
57 G of carbs of which 56 G of sugars
and 56 mg of sodium let's compare that
to a 99 G bar over here seeing as
there's only 1 G difference 500 calories
57.5 G of carbs 20 7.5 G of total fat
17.5 G of saturated fat 55 G of total
sugars 7.5 g of protein and 100 mg of
sodium if we compare the 100 G stats in
the UK to the 99 G stats in the US
you'll find that the UK actually has
slightly more calories and fat although
it has less carbs and much less
sodium I'm the watching current season
of a love Island UK some like are you
joking are you joking you're having a
laugh they have on a laugh this is
journalism baby this is why we went to
journalism school I didn't go to
journalism school so I have an excuse